audition que nous avons menées jusqu'à
présent monsieur le professeur je vous
remercie de votre présence avant de
débuter cette audition et nous donner la
parole pour un cours propos liminaire je
vais vous demander de prêter serment
en effet conformément à l'article 6 de
l'ordonance du 17 novembre 1958 relative
au fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires les personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
doivent prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
au delà de la sacralité attaché au
serment je tiens à rappeler aujourd'hui
qu'en cas d'obstruction de mensonges
dorfhüs de déférer à une convocation des
sanctions pénales peuvent être
appliquées certains allant jusqu'à cinq
ans d'emprisonnement
soixante quinze mille euros damende
monsieur je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et dire je le jure je jure
je vous remercie
je rappelle que cette audition est
public et ça vous l'avez vu elle est
donc diffusé en direct consultable en
vidéo et fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
qui sera publié monsieur professeur sans
plus attendre vous avez la parole
en termes de conflits d'intérêts je veux
signaler que j'ai un lien avec hitachi
pour le développement de microscopie
électronique en microbiologie clinique
et que je suis membre fondateur de 5
start up qui pour l'instant ont pas
rapporté d'argent
j'ai déjà fondé de khimki ce qui qui qui
ont coulé on verra bien car nadine sur
dix qui rend riche on verra donc les
quelques points dont je voulais vous
parler
premièrement pour pour essayer de situer
les choses la mortalité c'est très
compliqué de parler de la mortalité
parce que vous voyez sur le charles de
gaulle ya zéro mort sont jeunes on les
prend en charge relativement tôt si sur
le diamant une crique je crois que tu es
son nom il ya eu 2 % de morts c'est des
sujets plus âgés
donc on voit qu'il ya une variation dans
la gravité dans les ces vérités qui
dépendent de la population qui est
touché bien sûr donc c'est difficile de
faire des généralités il faut savoir
quelles sont les populations et la
manière dont on les a pris en charge
globalement si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé en europe
il ya eu un peu moins de deux cent mille
morts maintenant qu'on peut évaluer la
mortalité
par tranche d'âge est un élément qui est
important et qui doit amener à réfléchir
sur les stratégies de prise en charge
thérapeutique
il y a dix pour cent des gens
65 ans et dont 90 qui avait plus et 50%
qu'il y avait plus de 40 85 ans d'accord
donc c'est le sait les données qui sont
des données moyennes que l'onda qui
permettent de voir éventuellement
d'évaluer si on fait mieux si on fait
moins bien que la moyenne
ça c'est la moyenne il ya une disparité
donc moi je crois beaucoup
je crois beaucoup beaucoup à la aux
données chiffrées brut
je me méfie de tout les viscères
d'appeler ça les méthodes mathématiques
sont les habits d'hésiter donc je me
méfie beaucoup de la manière dont on
enrobe et on manipule les chiffres et à
la fin on n'y comprend plus rien j'aime
bien les données brutes ce que même si
bien sûr on doit le tempérer les morts
la perte d'espérance de vie de quelqu'un
qui a 85 ans quelqu'un qui à 20 ans
n'est pas la même bien entendu donc il
faut pondérer ça mais moi je tient aux
données brutes parce que financer les
moins manipulable
donc je pense qu'effectivement il y aura
un effort a demandé aux uns et aux
autres de transparence totale sur les
sur les sur les sur la mortalité
il ya des différences dont vous voyez
bien que les gens sur lequel les géants
se portant dans les régions françaises
sur la mortalité il y en a qui sont
liées à des phénomènes qu'on comprend
mal sont des phénomènes écologique c'est
les maladies d'écosystèmes la raison
pour laquelle dans le grand est et est
plus sévère qu'ailleurs
certainement un certain nombre de
raisons peut-être les rassemblements
religieux peut être des conditions on
comprend très mal l'épidémiologie des
malades quelque chose depuis très
longtemps tous les gens qui vous diront
que c'est simple son sont inconscients
ou ignorants de leur ignorance et tous
les gens qui me feront des modèles
projectif sur des maladies qu'on ne
connaît pas encore son des fous c'est
mon idée en tout cas est en tout cas ils
n'ont jamais raison on n'a pas
d'expérience de gens qui prédit
l'évolution d'une maladie qu'on connaît
pas il faudrait être fou pour penser
qu'on peut ces sites à peu des lieux
c'est une croyance aux mathématiques qui
finit par être de la religion donc on
aura un besoin et vous aurez un besoin
puisque on est proche de la fin de
données très précises pour voir ce qui
se passe et pour répondre aux questions
de pourriez moins deux morts essayé sur
la puce la deuxième chose en termes de
santé publique
il ya une véritable question qui s'est
posée pour moi cette question la santé
publique c'est 70 à 80% de politique et
20 à 30% de sciences et de médecine
et on a eu l'impression un certain
nombre de cas que des décisions
politiques que je crois à purement
politique le confinement le masse dans
la rue ces décisions politiques
il n'y a pas de données scientifiques
qui permettront jamais prouvé ça parce
que c'est des notion d'écosystème qui a
été déchargée sur des scientifiques et
des décisions médicales qui ont été
préemptés par le politique et sur lequel
là je suis vraiment désaccord donc je
crois qu'il ya une vraie réflexion à
savoir quelle est la part du politique
quelle est la part du médecin et quelle
est la part de scientifiques le
scientifique doit apporter de la
connaissance supplémentaires et sur une
maladie nouvelle c'est une connaissance
qui ne peut être que progressive effort
organisé la mise en place et la
progression de la connaissance
les médecins doivent faire le métier de
médecin qui est soignée et les
politiques doivent organiser la société
et la santé publique c'est toujours
difficile parce que la limite entre les
uns et les autres est toujours un peu
complexe sur le plan de la de la deûle à
l'épidémiologie il ya des choses très
particulier à cette maladie qui était
aussi imprévisible c'est que les enfants
sont très peu touché nous on nous avons
testé beaucoup et ce qui nous permet
d'avoir en france même une étude et
lépide des études épidémiologiques
on a trouvé que les chez les enfants de
moins d'un an est pratiquement pas chez
les moins de 5 ans extrêmement rarement
un peu plus entre 10 et 15 en est
réellement
ça n'est pas des comportements purement
des comportements puisqu'on a eu
l'occasion de faire maintenant une étude
qui est pas encore publié dans la
commune et de la communauté israélite
qui était très touché parce qu'ils
avaient une fête ça fait la fête de
pourim qui a fait des enfants auxquels
il ya beaucoup de regroupement on a eu
beaucoup de cas hospitalisés à ce moment
là et quand on a regardé communauté a
été très touchée on était très en
contact avec eux et on a fait une des
études dans la communauté et le taux d'
attaque chez les enfants est de l'ordre
de 20% alors que les adultes ils l'ordre
de 95%
donc dans les mêmes expositions et la
fed pour ims a fait des enfants on les
embrasse on les touche exactement comme
quand même a dû peut-être plus donc il
ya une non réceptivité des enfants qui
est quelque chose qui est unique dans
toutes les infections respiratoires
virales les enfants sont les plus
touchés et dans celle là ce sont les
moins touchées
mais c'était pas non plus prévisible je
sais ce que j'avais dit au président
sa décision de reprendre pour les écoles
les enfants sont pas peu touchés et
encore moins souvent malades
d'accord il est possible que il est
possible que ce soit il est possible que
ce soit lié à une immunité antérieure du
aux autres coronavirus qui circulent qui
eux sont beaucoup plus fréquents chez
les enfants et qui ont sévi quelques
mois avant donc il est bien possible y
avait des travaux y compris qu on l'a
déterré un peu anciens de 2013 qui
montrait ses réactions croisées entre
les commandes d'avions pour l'avenir de
cette maladie bien entendu le comme
disait victor hugo l'avenir est à dieu
il n'est pas nous je me permets juste
vous pourquoi vous entendez donc
l'avenir est imprévisible vous souvenez
que c'est napoléon que que victor hugo
disait ça je crois qu'il a raison il
faut laisser à chacun sa part de
responsabilités moi je prédis pas
l'avenir je fais pas ça le deuxième le
troisième point dangereux ou parler
rapidement
vous avez bien vu que c était un élan de
conflit dont je vous parlerai plus
longuement si vous voulez qui est celui
de la mise en place du traitement le
traitement
les premières données que nous ayons eue
sur le traitement concernant cette
maladie était tirée de des études qui
avaient été faites sur le sahara ce qui
montre et c'était manière amusante pas
aussi le président du ls avait déclaré
que le médicament dussart s'était
appelée rockin et puis les chinois ont
testé et ont rapporté la sensibilité à
la chloroquine même s'ils virent qu'ils
étaient publiés dans sa l'express et
ensuite on dit écoutez puisque qui ne
coûte rien on va faire la chloroquine
épisode vous rapporter les résultats
préliminaires et nous on a confirmé ses
résultats au laboratoire comme d'autres
en particulier associé avec avec
l'azithromycine c'est devenu sa a pris
une proportion cette guerre qui est
devenu une espèce de guerre pour contre
avec des mobiles derrière qui sont d'une
grande complexité
c'est rentré dans le contexte de la
vraie guerre civile qui existent
actuellement aux etats-unis entre les
démocrates et les républicains et donc
moi je connais pas je vous le dis voilà
publiquement sous peine d'aller en
prison alors 75000 euros du mans je ne
connais pas trop mais je ne connais pas
beau le temps je ne connais pas
et donc c'est pas moi qui leur ai dit
d'utiliser la chloroquine donc voilà
aidé mais il s'est trouvé une espèce de
frontières la chloroquine est recommandé
pour une population d'à peu près 4 5
milliards de personnes dans le monde
d'accord c'est difficile de penser que
et il ya une autre partie qui a
considéré et ses 2 2 sur tellement y
compris moi personnellement j'ai eu des
tensions comme jamais de ma vie de
journaux qui m'ont demandé si je sais
pas c'était vrai que j'avais oublié de
déclarer des conflits d'intérêts que
sanofi sinon l'on retiré mon papier qui
m'ont demandé si c'était vrai que je
n'avais pas eu l'accord de l'asn sur le
premier travail que nous avions
heureusement ont varié le papier ça
n'est jamais arrivé de ma vie qui est
une tension de cette nature là et vous
avez vu qu'elle est allée croissante
pour aller jusqu'à publier un papier que
n'importe qui de mon niveau considère
que c'est un faux dans le land 7 qui est
devenu en salle gates et transparent
pour quelqu'un de mon niveau que ce n'
est paraît il c'est la même équipe avait
publiée dans le new england on voyait
les les journaux on a été les deux
meilleurs niveaux sont les cibles les
plus choisis bien sûr et donc cette
notoriété en fait des cibles
incroyablement fragile et dans l'ue un
gandhi avait publié quelque chose que
comme député vous ne pouvez pas ignorer
il avait dit dedans il est courageux pas
combien d'hôpitaux français et que pour
toutes les personnes
il avait l'ethnicité et donc ça
l'ethnicité ça n'est pas autorisé par la
loi dans ce pays
donc ça n'est pas possible si ces gens
si c'était vrai mais analyser nous
n'avons pas ça dans tel et tel pays car
nous n'avons pas le droit de marquer
dans un dossier médical quelle ethnie
six aides qui existent complexe un nom
un peu complexe des gens dans un dossier
médical donc ça n'est pas possible donc
on savait que ses jantes et les menteurs
le point d'interrogation sur lequel
jusqu'à quel point ils sont menteurs moi
je pense que c'est en tirant fonds est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je
pensais ça dans le papier de l'en-tête
c'est que quand il rapportait le sexe
l'âge les facteurs de risque qui disait
qu'en afrique on fumait autant qu en
asie je vous assure que c'est pas vrai
lisez qu'on était aussi obèses en
afrique aux états unis et c'est pas vrai
à 0,4 ou 0,5 point près et c'est juste
pas vrai
donc il suffisait de lire et pas que le
titre
si vous voulez pour se rendre compte que
ce n'est pas vrai donc ça a pris une
ampleur extraordinaire et le lait je
reconnais que l'ampleur s'est associé à
des mouvements économiques que j'avais
jamais vu non plus un qui sont pour
appeler les choses par leur nom celle de
gilead pour lequel il s'est échangé
pendant cette période plus de plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'actions et qui
sont rythmées par les déclarations ça
marche ou les déclarations que la
chloroquine marche d'accord qu'il ne
marche pas donc il ya des enjeux qui
sont d'un niveau que je n'ai jamais
connu un mariage je suis pas un pigeon
de l'année donc j'ai jamais vu ça
donc c'est une question à mon sens chez
que la fed a commencé une enquête
là-dessus je pense qu'on pourra pas
éviter d'aller jusqu'au fond de cette
question qui est une question con c'est
extrêmement compliqué sur le plan de la
déteste et de la maladie l'âge exprime
une chose je ne suis pas d'accord avec
la décision qui a été prise de ne pas
généraliser les tests dès le début de
mars
l'om est à recommander de tester tous
les gens qui étaient suspects ou
contacter pour le coc vie de 19 il y
avait les moyens dans ce pays de le
faire la paix sert je sais pas si vous
voulez que je vous explique ce que c'est
que la pcr c'est d'une simplicité de
bébé la paix serre c'est la question du
micro souhaite un partis me croyant ça
pétera de la pcr c'est une simplicité de
bébé tout le monde sait faire ça si vous
voulez que je voulais explique je vous
l'expliquais sinon ce que vous la
connaissez suffit de changer les amorces
et donc tout le monde est capable de
faire ça tout le monde fait de la paix
serre nous on faisait 300 milles pcr par
an si vous dites qu'il faut rajouter
quelques milliers honnêtement et quand
on a commencé à faire tourner la machine
la linge et niort en charge de ça chez
moi a fait 1 458 le préparation de pc on
a fourni à tout le monde à l'iss à
toulon et c'est donc à voir ça le vrai
problème c'est l extraction et donc on a
acheté plusieurs machines pour pouvoir
différentes modes d'extraction parce que
c'était rapidement épuisé donc que et
pourquoi il fallait faire absolument la
pcr c'est parce que sinon on était
obligé une déraison m'excuser
la causalité toujours un peu compliqué
mais une des raisons beaucoup de choses
dans les problèmes que je soulève un qui
sont des problèmes structurels qui sont
anciens et qui sont structurels de vos
collègues me rappeler que je dis la même
chose en 2012
un des problèmes de fond ici c'est ce
que ce que les gens appellent un centre
national de référence lors il pouvait
pas y avoir de centre national de
référence pour ce coronavirus puisqu'il
n'existait pas alors je vois pas comment
on aurait pu désigner un ensemble de
références pour ça il ya des gens qui
ont dit c'est nous la référence et il
n'y a que nous qui pouvons avoir le
faire moi m'ont même dit au début que je
pouvais pas faire des diagnostics de
coronavirus qu'à moi donc c'est les
mêmes pcr et ces mêmes trucs on les
choisit puis voilà donc c'est pas vrai
donc il ya une part d'intoxication et
c'est moi qui ai expliqué excuses au
président pour la première fois et qui
lui ai redit vous savez la pcr c'est
très simple et tout le monde peut faire
et donc c'est pendant tout ce temps on
n'a pas dit la vérité
c'est un examen extrêmement ça banal
tout le monde est capable de le faire
ça peut être fait dans les labos privés
nous on a eu on a reçu des colis en a
profité en thelle seul en profiter des
vétérinaires qu'ils en a tous les
réactifs pour vous si vous voulez on
voulait mettre à disposition on vous les
donne nous ont donné on les a fait nous
mêmes les tests nous ont donné les de
quoi les faire donc il y avait de quoi
faire c'est pas des choses très
compliquées et c'était indispensable de
le faire parce qu'on ne connaissait pas
la maladie donc on ne pouvait pas cerner
à partir du moment où le test n'était
pas fait on ne pouvait pas étudier la
maladie et quand tout ce que l'on a
déduit sur la maladie on l'a déduit à
partir de la grippe et c'était pas vrai
par exemple une des grandes erreurs
considérables que l'on connaît
maintenant c'est que l'essoufflement la
disney est un très très mauvais signe de
cette maladie en réalité quand vous
commencez à les mâles dans la grippe
vous commencez à devenir insuffisant
respiratoire vous été soufflé parce que
vous ne n'avais pas beaucoup d'oxygène
et parce que vous avez beaucoup de
dioxyde de carbone un gaz carbonique et
c'est pour ça que vous commencez à être
essoufflée dans cette maladie avait été
décrit par les chinois ce que nous on a
retrouvé manière extrêmement commune ce
qu'on appelle l'hypoxie heureuse c'est à
dire c'est les gens qui ont une hypoxie
avec ses dires d'une
une pourcentage d'oxygène qui au lieu
d'être à 90 8 à 100% peuvent être à
95,92 nous on a eu des gens qui
n'étaient pas essoufflé qui avait 90
d'accord et ça si vous dites écouter ne
venait que quand vous serez essoufflé et
que les gens sont à 90 quand ils
viennent il va l'honorer a direct weemer
donc ça n'était pas un signe mais pour
pouvoir le savoir il fallait étudier les
mâles observation c'est toujours la
première étape mais pour observer il
faut faire du diagnostic
la deuxième c'est la raison pour
laquelle il s'était pas essoufflé qu'on
connaît nous depuis peu sap a été décrit
dans la littérature c'est que dans cette
maladie l'hypoxie n'est pas accompagnée
de ce qu'on voit d'habitude c'est à dire
une augmentation du carnet carbonique
mais d'une diminution du gaz carbonique
or ce qui rend et souffler c'est
l'augmentation du gaz carbonique et
cette diminution de gaz carbonique
associée à une diminution de l'oxygène
s'étaient connus que dans une seule
maladie pas dans la grippe s'étaient
connus dans l'embolie pulmonaire est
dans cette maladie on a découvert au fur
et à mesure qu'il y avait plein de
petites embolie pulmonaire
et c'est peut-être la raison pour
laquelle cette peau qui est très
atypique
la deuxième chose c'est que en dépit du
fait qu'il n'y avait pas de signes
pulmonaires mais ça les chinois l'avait
décrit ils font systématiquement des
scanners de l'aude aux pour remplacer le
territoriales ce qu'il faudra faire en
france mais on a un retard d'équipement
très anciens très importante
je vois bien grugés eh bien il ya 65 %
des gens qui n'ont pas de signes
respiratoires qui ont des légions au
scanner et parmi ces lésions il y en a
11 % qui ont des lésions sévères et qui
sont maintenant des gens chez qui on
retrouve des séquelles en particulier
des fibroses pulmonaires donc c'est
cette phase d'observation dont on s'est
privé en se privant du diagnostic a été
un point clé l'observation de tout c'est
ça et tout était bizarre dans cette
maladie mais il fallait l'étudier y
compris pour comprendre le traitement
c'est-à-dire que la maladie au départ
c'est le virus et puis ça devient une
association virus réponse immunitaire
ensuite c'est essentiellement réponse
immunitaire il ya presque plus de virus
et ensuite c'est même plus une réponse
immunitaire c'est de légionelles ca les
tissus sont détruits et là c'est la
qualité du soin qui compte et c'est la
qualité du soin qu'on mesure voyez il ya
donc quatre étapes et dans ses quatre
étapes l'idée qu'on va donner le même
médicament aux quatre étapes et sa
maintenance
fantasy et ça on le sait depuis la
grippe parce que pour la grippe le
tamiflu de liliane ne marche que pendant
les deux premiers jours ça marche pas le
dernièrement parce que la réponse
immunitaire dur et c'est presque toutes
les maladies infectieuse aiguë qui sont
comme ça donc la question était mal
posée de savoir leur aide leur m d'ici
d'hier ne pouvait pas marcher sur les
formes graves
c'était pas possible le seul moment où
il pouvait marcher c'est sur le et
forment des buts ce qui a été démontré
mais ils pouvaient pas être prescrits et
l'informent de début banal pour une
raison c'est que il ya 8 à 10%
insuffisance rénale par rapport à l'om
décidèrent donc il à la fenêtre dans
lequel ça peut fonctionner me paraît
extrêmement extrêmement faible le encore
une fois il ya une grande une grande
folie sur le hydroxy claudine qui est en
train le flux et le reflux est en train
de venir et puis il ya beaucoup de
travaux dans les nôtres pour faire des
analyses y ait eu que quatre études
randomisées dont trois disques hydroxy
claudine marche mieux que le placebo
bien lui que quatre en tout et donc peu
importe le temps fera son tri là aussi
on a l'habitude en sciences les gens se
disputer la fin le temps fait mais
globalement il y a eu là dessus une
émotion et je le dis là encore une fois
parce que c'est ce que je pense je pense
que le mini ça a été mal entouré à ce
stade là parce qu'il faut avoir des
remparts quand on est politique il faut
avoir des gens qui soient capables
d'analyser les articles qu'ils soient
capables de dire écoutez ça c'est
raisonnable ça allait pas de manière à
ce qu'on se retrouve par la situation au
milieu du week-end à faire les
déclarations sans que personne ait
vraiment lui et papier et encore une
fois dans les auditions que vous aurez
ou peut-être vous n'aurez pas moi j'ai
été très frappée parce que je ne connais
que dominique maraninchi qui était le
prédécesseur du directeur de la ms n est
fait avec le prédécesseur du directeur
de l'ads du président de la haute
autorité de santé une tribune ensemble
en disant qu'ils étaient en désaccord
donc je pense que c'est intéressant
d'avoir leurs visions contradictoires
pour montrer que c'était pas de la
science dont on parlait mais c'était
choix personnel je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir je vous dis pas le cas la
raison vous ferez votre idée je pense
que vous vous imaginez je pense
processeur qu'on va passer à l'échangé
avec les parlementaires qui ont beaucoup
de questions à vous poser si vous voulez
bien
avant de passer la parole rapporteur moi
j'avais deux questions à vous poser 3
vous avez exprimé à plusieurs reprises
et vous venez de le faire d'une autre
manière
un regard critique la réponse qui ont
apporté les pouvoirs publics à cette
crise quelle décision aurait dû être
prise selon vous par exemple vous avez
indiqué des doutes sur le bien-fondé du
confinement total donc j'aimerais avoir
votre retour là dessus deuxièmement
votre position face à la gravité de la
crise et l'évolution de l'épidémie a été
amenée à évoluer
finalement au cours de la crise vous
aussi puisque dans un entretien à bfm le
30 avril vous estimiez très peu probable
l'hypothèse d'une seconde vague
vous êtes revenu sur votre analyse le 19
juin pour quelles raisons votre
appréciation at elle évolué ce son
retour éventuel d'une épidémie sur
quelles données
d'ailleurs on peut considérer ce retour
possible et enfin d'une manière plus
générale quelles leçons doit-on tirer de
cette gestion de crise
le premier point jeu comme comme je les
dis et je le jeu je le redis les
décisions la décision du confinement
comme la décision des masses dans la rue
les masques ne repose pas sur des
données scientifiques établis claire et
démontrable ça sera jamais démontré
d'ailleurs il ya des études qui sortent
maintenant qu'ils y écouter ça marche
mieux quand on confine ça marche mieux
quand on confine pas il ya un point sur
lequel je suis assez convaincu je pense
que les rassemblements sous les dents
les situations telles que celles là sont
déraisonnables
après le confinement à la maison il y à
des phénomènes c'est vraiment et je les
dis deux fois au président
c'est un domaine politique qui m'échappe
parce que c'est celui de la gestion de
la population de la crainte de la
population
est-ce que c'est plus grave d'être
terrifiée de partir d'avoir les deux
tiers des gens qui partent des villes
est ce que c'est donc c'est une gestion
politique sur lequel je me suis interdit
d'avoir une opinion quant à la deuxième
place avec douceur ce fantasme
journalistique mais j'ai jamais dit ça
ce que j'ai dit c'est que j'ai montré
que que j'ai pu dire
au président que je ne le pensais qu'on
si les choses se passaient comme elle se
passe en général avec les maladies qui
sont en cloche nous commencé puisqu'on
avait un mois d'avancé puisque ici ont
compté les morts et moi je comptais les
positif donc on voyait qu'on en avait
passé le sommet de la courbe et qu'on
est en train de redescendre et qu'on
pouvait voir où est ce que la courbe
allait s'arrêter qu'elle est arrêtée en
mai ou à peu près l'armée donc c'est ce
que je lui ai dit après si on vient de
faire un très gros travail que j'ai
présentée aussi je pense que c'est de là
que vient le malentendu sur le fait
qu'on a mesurée quelle était la courbe
exactement des quatre coronavirus
saisonniers qui est exactement la même
il ya quatre autres coronavirus qui
sévissent depuis longtemps qui font 8 à
10% une infection respiratoire dans
l'année qui sont exactement de la même
manière mais qui sévissent pendant la
saison froide
il ya qui commence entre janvier et mars
et qui vont jusqu'à avril ou mai et donc
la courbe est la même et donc parmi les
hypothèses possibles il ya une hypothèse
que cette maladie devienne une maladie
saisonnière comme les autres coronavirus
qu'elle disparaisse comme le sar ce
purement et simplement à la fin de
l'épidémie ou toute autre hypothèse les
deux hypothèses les plus plausibles et
tant que ce soit que ça disparaisse
complètement ça va dépendre du nombre de
porteurs chroniques ça va dépendre de la
en particulier ce qui entretient les
infections de l'hémisphère nord c'est
leur circulation dans l'hémisphère sud
et que donc chez dur expliqué parce que
je pense que ce n'est pas clair
l'hémisphère sud à une inversion des
saisons donc l'hiver c'est maintenant
dans l'hémisphère sud
et comme la nouvelle zélande et à une
latitude qui est la même que la nôtre
sur l'hémisphère sud
et bien si il y à une épidémie de
coronavirus actuellement en nouvelle
zélande qui débute on peut se dire mon
dieu est bien possible que nous en ont
reprenions et qu'elle devienne
saisonnière l'année prochaine pendant la
saison froide
le jeu est ce que c'est clair donc j'ai
pas parlé ni de rebond n'est jamais
prononcé le mot deuxième vague qui est
un mot que je réserve à ce qu'ils
utilisent et je ne les jamais utilisé
sauf pour vous répondre
alors moi je me suis appuyée que sur les
déclarations que j'ai lu pas sur vos
comme une passion que je ne suis pas au
courant
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
professeur de votre présence aujourd'hui
devant notre commission à l'assemblée
nationale
vous l'avez dit dans votre propos
liminaire votre action votre
positionnement a suscité une multitude
de réactions passionnelles que l'on n'a
pas l'habitude de voir dans une
situation de crise sanitaire vous êtes
ou hays ou adulé et avec peu de nuances
entre les deux j'ai même vu ce matin
dans une chaîne info que d'une boutique
marseillaise avait réalisé des bougies à
votre effigie et qu'elle rencontrait un
très grand un très grand succès vous
avez fait l'objet de propos violents je
voudrais avoir votre sentiment pour
mesurer si cette passion qui quelquefois
a pris de façon assez générale une
tournure un peu irrationnel et est
compatible avec la sérénité que l'on
peut attendre de la gestion d'une crise
sanitaire que ce soit en matière de
médecine ou ou 2 ou de recherche
vous êtes venu vers nous aujourd'hui je
vous renouvelle et réitère notre
gratitude
le président de la république est venu à
vous le 9 avril dernier puisqu'il a
effectué un déplacement à marseille un
pur pour vous écoutez donc vous avez
évoqué à plusieurs reprises dans votre
première intervention des indications
que vous lui avez donné ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que vous lui avez dit quels conseils
quelle appréciation sur la stratégie
sanitaire qui est conduite depuis le
mois de janvier sur cette crise et
comment il a reçu sans trahir votre
conversation mais elle est importante
pour nous ses conseils je voudrais
également vous vous demandez pourquoi
alors que vous aviez été désigné le
11 mars je crois par un décret justement
le président de la république vous avez
démissionné du conseil scientifique
qu'elle différend sur la forme sur le
fond vous a opposé aux membres du
conseil scientifique
je laisserai à nos collègues mes
collègues vous vous interrogez sur la
il vous l'avez largement abordée c'est
au coeur des débats nous le savons
évoqué la question de du traitement que
vous avez initié au sein de l'institut
universitaire de hospitalo universitaire
de marseille sur l'idh roxy chloroquine
vous vous lavez largement abordée mais
je voudrais m'attarder un peu plus sur
la question des tests parce que je crois
que là pour le coup tout le monde vous
reconnaît et tout le monde reconnaît à
10 h et que vous avez été un pionnier
que vous avez été sans doute au sein de
votre institut celui qui a testé le plus
massivement le plus rapidement le plus
précocément le niçois que je suis dit oh
marseillais que vous n'êtes que nous
avons été amenés à bénéficier de vos
ceux de vos services et vous l'avez fait
vous l'avez dit très très largement
comment vous réalisiez presque un quart
des tests dans votre institut par
rapport à tout ce qui a été réalisé en
france
oc puisque le président du conseil
scientifique jean françois delfraissy
que nous avons entendu l'a dit lui même
que s'il y a eu la nécessité du
confinement je cite ces propos c'est
parce que nous manquions cruellement de
tests au début de la crise trois mille
tests par jour alors que l'allemagne en
réalisé 58 comment avez vous pu
mobiliser des moyens matériels humains
comment avez vous pu coordonner cette
action pour faire en sorte que ces
textes ces tests soient réalisés aussi
massivement et je voulais vous
interroger aussi par rapport à ce sujet
des tests sur l'organisation
administrative sur les décisions qui ont
peut-être et j'aimerais connaître votre
position a mené des retards
considérables dans la mise en oeuvre de
ces tests derrière il y as peut-être un
trop grand nombre de structures qui
avait été choisi un écartant les
laboratoires vétérinaires certains
laboratoires publics les laboratoires
privés au début est-ce que c'est cela
qui est la cause la base des retards et
qu'est ce qui devrait être organisée
différemment pour que si demain et vous
évoquiez cette probabilité
nous sommes confrontés un nouvelle phase
épidémique pandemic nous soyons en
matière de tests enfin opérationnel je
vous remercie show merci je suis ravi de
venir mais comme vous me l'avez écrit
des gentils pas expliqué je n'avais pas
le choix non mais je le fais volontiers
il faut remonter et je m'excuse c'est un
c'est un malheur de l'âge d'avoir de
l'expérience mais faut que ça serve à
quelque chose c'est bien pire que notre
rencontre là le moment où j'ai pris
conscience lucidement que ce pays
n'était plus prêt du tout c'est 2001 en
2001 à fantasmes chaque jour je vous
recommande de lire mon livre sans faire
de publicité de ça commence comme ça en
2001 on les aux états unis et aux états
unis seulement on envoie des enveloppes
avec une poudre blanche qui se révèlent
être de l'anthrax il y à quelques morts
les choses s'arrêtent les américains ne
le disent pas mais en réalité ils savent
très vite que c'est un truc endogène
c'est à dire que c'est une souche qui
vient d'une forte des tricks qui a été
militarisé par les américains qui a été
emporté par l'ingénieur qui métallisé ça
au moment où nixon a décidé en 69
d'arrêter les la culture de l'anthrax
comme arme de bioterrorisme
il ya eu une la même folie que vous
trouvez la manne en nous la trouvons à
cette époque là où les gens on a mis
déjà en prison parce qu'ils mettaient
sur une lettre vivent au delà des nous
parce que il a émis delà de la farine et
c'est donc là même les plantes
présentées mauvais goût ont amené à
mettre en prison des gens devant la peur
des gens d'accord fermer des écoles jean
mettait un peu de farine dans un coin et
rapidement on a été confrontés nous à
marseille ça et on s'est rendu compte
que personne ne pouvait le faire quand
on était les seuls à avoir un p 3 à
l'époque l'état avait exigé à trois
raisons que ça soit fait par des
gnostiques par culture et donc on a fait
le tiers des poutres du pays hanté les
seuls à répondre en 24 heures dans le
test et les autres ont été répandues
parfois qu'un mois de retard je dis pas
que ça serve à quelque chose
aucun n'a été positif mais en tout cas
c'est ce que demandaient les
représentants de la population qu'on les
teste et donc on s'est rendu compte à ce
moment là a paris je peux vous dire il
ya zéro tests ne sont faits les gens qui
étaient censés cultiver la tuberculose a
pitié où on les techniciens ont fait un
droit de retrait en disant écoutez on
veut pas cultiver ça parce que c'est
dangereux quand on n'a pas l'habitude et
que donc ça ça m'a posé la question de
la gestion de crise qui était une fausse
crise mais qui était une crise quand
même quand ils ces crises
je crois donc je veux mettre les choses
en perspective même si je pense qu'elle
est chose qui aurait pu être mieux géré
il y avait déjà dans ce pays un problème
de fond qui est qui gère ça alors le
point auquel j'en suis arrivée donc la
suite que que vous connais je passais je
pensé que quand jean françois mattei et
de l'humidité de la santé que madame et
nury et 2 des mises à recherche ils
m'ont demandé une mission dont je
souhaitais depuis le début qu'elle soit
plus généralement les crises en maladies
infectieuses mais kouchner avait dit à
mater inondant seule chose importante
c'est le bioterrorisme donc j'ai dû
négocier un peu mais j'arrive pour que
je ne fasse pas que le bioterrorisme et
les crises en maladies infectieuses et
donc ça m'a amené à la fin conclure
écouter finalement je n'ai pas exprimé
comme ça c'est maintenant que j'ai pris
comme ça finalement vous et les deux
dans l'histoire de l'humanité si les
gens ont tellement peur des épidémies
c'est que les choses qui ont changé
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est les
guerres les épidémies et donc je pense
bon j'en suis que c'est un domaine
régalien et que donc nous n'avons pas la
capacité d'avoir un modèle réhab bien
là dessus c'est ce que je dis maintenant
lié à chuter comme un fort à la vauban
et je propose et je vous assure je
propose n'est pas monsieur je t'es
content qu'un mariage il faut qu'il y en
ait 7 en france dont un à paris à lyon à
lille pour avoir un endroit dans lequel
on puisse recevoir les malades dans
lequel on puisse faire des milliers de
tests dans lequel on puisse faire de la
recherche et de la veille
épidémiologique on peut pas faire la
veille de tout un pays de 65 millions
d'habitants
à saint maurice je pensais ça et je
pense encore et j'ai écrit ça 2003 line
vous pouvez le dire
donc je n'ai pas changé d'avis et nous
sommes restés par confort ou parfums des
coûts bien alors par le rythme politique
qui change trop vite on avait calculé
que la durée dhabi ni de la santé de ces
deux ans et demi c'est ici on prépare
les choses avancent ça va mais si c'est
pas préparé à l'avancé impossible c'est
pas ça et donc si vous voulez comme sur
d'espérance de vie comme budget de la
santé est très faible
sa capacité à mettre en place est
d'ailleurs celle de jean françois mattei
a pas été très long non plus ou moins
que ça mais dans les recommandations que
je lui faisais j'avais mis et c'était un
sujet de dispute avec son cabinet qu'il
fallait surveiller au jour le jour la
mortalité parce que s'il y avait une
mortalité de quelque chose d'inconnu
on ne le saurait pas c'est l'analyse de
la mortalité n'était jamais fait arrêter
s'était confiée à l'inserm et quand il a
ressorti l'analyse la mortalité
il a eu la surprise que de voir que
depuis la guerre il y avait eu en
réalité si pic de mortalité 3 de grippe
et 3 de canicule que personne arrive et
qui était dé chaque fois des pics de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes
personne ne surveillait la mortalité est
quelque chose que je connais parce que
dans les maladies infectieuses de
maladies légionnaires et le sida ont été
découverts sur des données comme ça d'
analyse systématique ce qu'on appelle la
surveillance syndromique celles qui ne
passe pas par des moustiques donc pour
trouver les choses inconnues on ne peut
pas compter sur le diagnostic
c'est quand on les connaît quand on le
connaît on va rejouer donc depuis cette
époque là je pense ça ça n'a pas été mis
en place mais après je me suis convaincu
moi même j'étais un peu découragé mais
je suis allé j'ai été invité à shanghai
et quand j'ai été à shanghai j'ai eu un
choc en 2005 j'ai vu en réponse aux ars
en deux ans il avait fait quelque chose
qui est
fois le chu et y est mieux équipé que
lee a chu et qui est mieux équipé klich
donc ça m'a redonné le goût de delà de
relancer ce projet et ce projet au lieu
de passer comme ce qu'il aurait dû être
un projet régalien est devenu un projet
de recherche tant mieux on fait beaucoup
de recherches qui intègre et la
construction d'un centre de soins et
d'observation et d'un centre de lutte
contre les crises
et donc c'est une vraie donc le la
nécessité de ça c'est quelque chose pour
moi au calme moi je crois depuis 20 ans
donc je suis encore plus convaincu
qu'avant mais qui a été difficile à
mettre en place parce que encore une
fois ça remet en cause notre manière
d'organiser les choses
on a eu juste qu'il y à 50 ans un
institut pasteur où il y avait des
malades qui faisait des milliers de
diagnostic hills et d'épidémiologie
c'est plus vrai l'institut pasteur est
devenu un institut de recherche
fondamentale dans lequel cette activité
marginale
vous pouvez pas dire que vous allez
gérer une crise avec des gens qui n'ont
pas les malades ni les moyens de faire
10000 20000 30000 pcr par jour c'est pas
possible ça ça peut se faire que dans
les hôpitaux que dans les ch et l'inserm
et partie des chu l'institut pasteur n'y
est pas et donc si vous n'êtes pas une
réflexion de fond d'une part sur mailler
le territoire de centres capables de
faire face à une crise et pas qu'à
marseille et sur la réflexion qu'il y as
d'imposer sa et pas de laisser le jeu
parce que nous avons aussi le jeu des
nôtres d'élections dcm eu des
changements de directeurs d'hôpitaux
nous on en change tous les deux ans est
dure comme les lisent la santé madame le
directeur
donc on peut pas mettre des plans avec
ça il faut que l'état dit l'écouté voilà
dans chaque zone de défense
je dois avoir un centre très capables de
m'aider à gérer une crise de maladies
infectieuses y compris si cette crise se
révèle à la fin être une crise factice
ça fait partie d'un domaine je pense
régalien de l'état monsieur plus
d'autres questions comme bâle était sur
les tests commencent à l'azeri temps
était sur les tests c'est la même chose
c'est à dire que je suis très offre bien
que j'en ai un
j'ai un centre national de référence les
deux
mais je suis hostile aux centres
nationaux de référence si les centres
nationaux de référence devienne le petit
monopole ou le terrain de chasse des
gens qui font ça j'ai déjà eu ça pour
ebola j'ai beaucoup protesté on nous
empêchait de faire la paix cpcr pour
ebola en dehors du p4 de lyon
donc quand on avait un malade il fallait
envoyer le prélèvement sérum de
marseille à lyon lors des gens nés il ya
une histoire à tous longue comme ça deux
malheureux car il ya paludisme mais quel
malheur d'arriver au moment où tout le
monde avait peur des mots là alors il
avait déjà piqué tout d'un coup il ya
quelqu'un qui dit pourquoi pas et bola
alors il est plus le droit de le piquer
épique et samedi donc ils nous l'ont
embarqué à marseille pour qu'on le pic
mais nous on n'avait pas le droit de le
tester
on fait tout pour le faire il ya des
réactifs qui était commercialisé pour
faire le diagnostic des mollahs mais il
a fallu l'envoyer à lyon pour que ça
fait lors ceux qui ont compris qu'il
fallait pas le faire à la fin c'est les
militaires à paris rendez vous ennuyer
avec aurel on va le faire chez nous a
déjà d'accord mais donc il faut voir
comment le fait d'avoir un centre de
référence comporte en permanence le
risque ça devient l'homme de l'année si
vous voulez de de dire écoutez voilà
c'est ma maladie c'est moi qui le fais
je rien qu'on m'enlève nouveau centre de
référence je m'excuse de dire ça ça fait
de la peine je j'ai rien contre lui mais
nous on a demandé à bruno lina nous
envoler ressouche tout de suite pour
avoir un témoin positif vivent plutôt
que faire un témoin auditif artificielle
nous a jamais répondu et c'est une
situation de crise d'accor donc il faut
faire attention les humains sont des
humains si vous confiez si vous voulez
la sécurité du pays à des gens qui
considèrent c'est leur affaire
personnelle je pense que vous ne voyez
pas ce qu'est la nature des
responsabilités que nous essayons
d'avoir collectivement donc ça moi j'ai
fait ça je voulais ça a été fait dans la
douleur
je vous assure les hug si vous lisez son
histoire folle à lire et pour l'ide ça a
été fait dans la douleur ça continue ça
a été fait dans la douleur mais moi je
j'estime que il estime maintenant que
j'ai fait mon devoir
on a amené maintenant la preuve de
concept que qu'il fallait avoir quelque
chose de cette nature et il fallait en
avoir je crois plusieurs pour pas qu'on
dise écouter y'a qu'à marseille et qu'on
arrive à faire s'écrouler le drôle de
mentalité qu'on arrive à avoir des
statistiques sur les données
donc je crois que je voulais qu'on ait
l'occasion qui fait le larron
possibilité de faire cette démonstration
que l'état doit se saisir de cette
affaire des épidémies mais dès que vous
allez au ministère moi j'ai vu j'avais
rendez vous avec quand j'étais chargé de
mission chez mattei celle haut
fonctionnaire défense et l'inra disait
mais non c'est nous pasteur disent non
c'est nous même s'il était fermée le
week-end le seul truc qui sont ouverts
jour et nuit qui soit ouvert le week-end
seul chu dans les institutions
il ya des gardes parce qu'il ya des gens
tout le temps donc si vous en voyez ça
pasteur à sept heures du soir qui c'est
qui va le recevoir
donc c'est pas réaliste c'est un autre
temps donc dans cet autre temps ce qui
fonctionne jour et nuit
ces grossières et là vous avez du
personnel et là vous pouvez mobiliser
des gens et là vous pouvez vous
organisez là vous avez des machines et
donc je crois que dans ces gros chu il
faut regrouper les médecins
infectiologues et les microbiologistes
qu'ils sont capables de faire la
biologie moléculaire ça doit former un
ensemble qui y répondre d'une manière
unanime et si on fait ça eh bien on est
capables nous on a bien sûr beaucoup
d'équipements sais je vous invite pour
ceux qui sont pas venus à venir voir les
haches et bien entendu on a un
suréquipement pour faire face aussi bien
à aux défis technologiques qui est une
autre chose qui m'inquiète je trouve
qu'il n'ya plus que les gens d'extrême
orient qui sont qui ont un niveau
scientifique compétitif
moi je ne vois plus en europe et aux
états unis qui est de ce niveau là je ne
vois plus en plus au niveau compétitif
technologie qui est impressionnant et
donc je regrette que nous on est là
soient les seuls à faire la course
technologique à ce point avec l'extrême
orient mais on est parfaitement capable
vous savez pour faire la paix serre si
vous avez un synthétiseur pour faire vos
amorce et que vous réalisez vous-même
les les
la préparation vous avez vous pouvez
faire des pc à tout ce que vous voulez
ou pour en faire autant que vous voulez
professeur je me permets juste rappeler
que le rapporteur vous posez la question
des
des tests dépistage quel était votre
avis sur la question s'être si je madame
la présidente si vous mais autorisée il
faut qu'on comprenne bien ce que vous
reprochez à l'organisation que vous vous
êtes naturellement plonger dans le sujet
par rapport à ceux cnr dont vous
critiquez où on était un peu en cause la
prééminence le rapport diffusion plus
large si j'aime si j'ai bien compris
mais on voudrait mesurer exactement dans
l'organisation actuelle
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné qu'est ce qui ne va pas on
prend vos pistes de réforme et je prêt
qu'on apprécie bien l'organisation que
je crois que c'est capital cette
question des tests vous l'avait dit et
on doit aller au bout si vous voulez la
réflexion qui a été menée mais je
n'imaginais pas que dans ce domaine le
la manière dont ça s'est organisé est
totalement archaïque solide et qui a des
centre national de référence de
diagnostic est une idée qui est qui qui
date de 40 ans je sais pas actuellement
il ya quelque chose qu'on appelle le
multiplexage hélas comme quelqu'un une
infection respiratoire il ya vingt virus
a testé et on teste les vins d'un coup
on va pas demanderont pape a envoyé sa à
quatre endroits en france soit 5 à 6
pour savoir comment on fait c'est une
autre époque
nous on n'en est même plus là on en est
à faire du séquençage massif dedans et
on sait qu'en ce tour roberts qui a et
on a ça dans les deux ou trois heures
nous le premier le premier cas qu'on ait
eu de 5 à 10 soit le premier cas de
roncq ont eu de positif
si vous voulez en 8 heures on avait le
génome entier d'accord donc où on est et
ça pouvait être n'importe quel virus
donc c'est pas et quant à identifier
ensuite ce virus sur une banque de
l'informatique sur essai il n'y a pas de
spécialisation là dessus qu'ils aient
vous idée des centres spécialisés pour
suivre la bibliographie et donc avoir
une bibliographie parfaite c'est très
bien mais pour faire du diagnostic
sourire on est dans une autre époque et
donc on a manqué là une étape 1
donc l'idée qu'il faut avoir nous on est
centre de référence pour l'erika dit
parce que époque la sérologie ray kadist
c'est très difficile enfin c'est
dérisoire si vous voulez si la plupart à
part dans les niches
il ya des tests diagnostiques qui
arrivent sur le marché et là je m'excuse
voyez pour revenir sur l'essai n'est
qu'en france on dise écouter
les tests qui sont marqués au marquage
qui sont passés au marquage c'est eux et
elles fbi et il faut que les centres de
référence français d'ici sont bons c'est
ça frise le ridicule je sais pas comment
ça pas fait éclater de rire tout le
monde ou alors en france on sait mieux
il ya 200 ans nationaux de référence et
ils savent mieux que la vie' ou le
marquage chez eux ce qu'on doit faire
face à pas de sens qui plus est c'est
pas vrai parce qu'en fonction du degré
de sensibilité vous avez détecté ou pas
les réactions croisées donc il ya des
techniques sérologique elles valent ce
qu'elles valent on voit mal comment le
le cnr pasteur dire écoutez ça qui est
validée par l'efs dié par le marquage
chez eux ça marche pas donc cette idée
que l'on peut réinventer les choses en
france dans un petit centre référence
c'est pas vrai je vous donne être un
autre exemple celui là vous paraîtra pas
suspect on a une énorme épidémie il ya
plusieurs vagues d'épidémie d'une
infection qui s'appelle clostridium
difficile et qui m'inquiète beaucoup qui
est très difficile le centre national de
référence est un bon copain à moi j'veux
pas suspect s'est réuni à nice quand dès
qu'il ya eu dix cas il a dit mais moi je
les fais plus je suis pas capable à nice
avec ce que j'ai de faire la culture de
ça et les génomes de ça je sais pas le
faire et look bien sûr on les a faits
nous on a fait 10 par semaine des
génomes deux côtés lobs je pars pas
d'être d'accord
donc c'est il ya un effet taillé un
effet équipements actuellement qui est
la réponse on ne peut plus avoir s'ils
voulaient cette vision regarder on est à
paris et on distribue comme ça un petit
peu on saupoudre un peu alors comme ça
personne est vexé lui tient tête ça
comme virus-là dire ça et cette
proposition elle doit pas dire j'avais
fait la faille pas c'est d'ailleurs
auprès de didier rous a encore dû
récemment en disant il faut laisser deux
centres comme ça pour vous faire les
maladies émergentes il faut que les
voulait doté financièrement
raisonnablement et on vous fera tout à
la fois parce que les équipements vous
permettent de tout faire à la fois
qu'est ce que c'est ce que les chinois
ont fait un sans thil ont pas un centre
pour les nouveaux virus un centre pour
les nouveaux corona ils ont des cendres
sont capables de détecter tout à la fois
donc il faut pouvoir avoir de la culture
virale il faut pouvoir avoir deux
de quoi faire des jaloux du séquençage
massif il faut pouvoir avoir de la
microscopie électronique il faut pour je
m'excuserais vu que ça peut être un
conflit d'intérêts pour moi voilà donc
je je je pense que cette organisation
c'est ce que j'écrivais ya 20 ans est
désuète
je n'ai pas changé d'avis c'est j'espère
que c'est pas par le gâtisme mais je
crois que moi je ne tiens pas du tout à
ce que nous ayons un monopole de la
recherche sur les marges j'ai toujours
dit le contraire il en faut s'attendre
france jean sérien aussi switch cancer
mais là aussi ce sont des décisions
politiques mais il faut que l'état
s'empare de ça et ne laisse pas faire
une auto gestion des maladies
infectieuses dans ce pays avec quelques
tout petits centres nationaux de
référence samedi temps et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle ensuite quand unis
une aubaine de cette nature arrive les
gens disent et moi c'est moi c'est moi
c'est moi et les choses deviennent
difficiles et donc je ne suis pas je les
dis en face à delfraissy je ne suis pas
d'accord qu'on ne pouvait pas faire les
tests on pouvait les faire à condition
de dire écoutez on doit les faire et
puisqu'on doit les faire on va les faire
comment on fait d'accord et bien sûr moi
j'aurais été ravi de donner mon opinion
mais c'est jamais bon l'opinion vous
demandez pourquoi je suis pas resté dans
ce conseil scientifique c'est parce que
je considérais que c'était pas un
conseil scientifique et que je ne fais
pas je ne fais pas de présence pas le
temps et donc les gens qui étaient là
n'était pas je sais ce que c'est un
conseil scientifique moi j'ai un conseil
scientifique pour les acheteurs qui fait
rêver le monde entier de qualité c'est
que des stars de leur domaine
c'est pas ça c'est un conseil
scientifique pour moi c'était pour
donner des conseils scientifiques
déterminer quels étaient les projets
scientifiques s'étaient pas à nous de
réfléchir sur le confinement ou son truc
personne ne sait répondre à ça donc les
discussions qu'elle avait dans ce
conseil scientifique ne me concernait
pas d'accord moi je veux bien parler de
science je veux bien parler de médecine
donc si on avait abordé ces questions et
quand j'ai appris que les essais avaient
été déterminées par iad aide vous gaza
d' en dehors de tout conseil
scientifique les le projet scientifique
lancé par le ministère de la recherche
effet en dehors de tout combiner deux
scientifiques
donc c'est pas un conseil scientifique
je poste 2 c mais c'est pas moi le
premier conseil scientifique que j'ai
dirigé ce temps 1989 m'excuse sa fille
anne-sophie ça fait longtemps
j'en ai dirigé dans ma fac qu'au
ministère de la recherche en 93 donc je
sais ce que c'est c'est pas ça le
conseil scientifique c'est pas une bande
de types l'habitude de travailler entre
eux et qu'ils discutent et aux questions
pendant cette occasion pensez pas ça
c'est des données des données et des
données qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
et qu'est ce qu'on propose maintenant de
pratique pour faire la science et vous
et c'était pas le cas je ne suis pas
fâché j'ai dit je ne veux pas faire de
signe de désapprobation public
donc je n'ai pas démissionné et j'ai dit
je continuerai à vous informer sur ce
que je ferai et je n'ai jamais cessé de
communiquer avec le musée de la santé
évoluent avec l'elysée tout pas mais pas
à travers ce comité qui ne me paraissait
pas un comité ad courage de discuter
j'aurais dû écouter soulèvement faire un
comité scientifique voilà je vous donne
est dit non des types qui veulent s
lemieux coronavirus en france il y avait
des gens n'avaient aucun de ceux qui
connaissent et de grenades les rues sans
que dans le conseil scientifique
il suffit de regarder il ya des sites
pour ça s'appelle ex expert skate vous
regardez les 20 premiers français qui
avaient publié sur coronavirus y en
avait aucun donc c'est quand même s'est
passé ça la science après vous regardez
donc moi je n'étais pas d'accord c'était
et c'est une vraie question que j'avais
déjà soulevé ces deux questions que
j'avais déjà soulevé dans mon dans mon
rapport aux mini c'était les conflits
d'intérêts vous pouvez le lire
en 2003 j'avais dit elle il faut faire
attention aux conflits d'intérêts les
conflits d'intérêts représente un
véritable problème et ils vont nous
polluer vous allez depuis le médiator
vous aurez rendez vous et les autres
mais au bout d'un mois il faudra s'en
occuper pour de bon dominique marananchi
quand il était directeur la lsm avec
xavier bertrand a mis en place santé
gouv qui était transparent santé bouffe
qui est très bien il faut s'en servir
faut le regarder
regardez ce qui se passe et donc quand
les gens ont des conflits d'intérêts il
ne me serait pas réservé de choses qui
qui a eu des conflits d'intérêts dont
celle du conseil scientifique ou dans la
périphérie
soucy et rend peut-être pour vous pas
forcément pour nous écouter vous avez
c'est pas compliqué vous avez un site
qui est très bien parce que l'e-santé
govou transparent santé gouv c'est un
peu compliqué parce qu on mélange tout
et on mélangeait les repas etc
mais sinon il ya un site qui regroupe
tout ça pas l'euro fort knox vous avez
qu à regarder mettez tous les noms euro
fort knox
tout ce que je vous dis c'est tout sur
internet c'est simple comme chou et au
bout d'un moment quand les gens vont
regarder vous regardez trop fort que
vous regardez et donc moi je vous ai dit
j'ai un conflit d'intérêts qui tâche qui
est la seule fois où j'ai parlé de
microscopie électronique j'ai rappelé
que j'avais parce que c'est vrai
on est incontestable ça veut dire que je
n'ai pas le droit de parler de quelque
chose de recommander quelque chose qui a
un lien que le lien soit pro ou contre
parce que du coup ça revient sur
l'hydroxyde go qu'il a entendu un
d'accord donc la question des conflits
d'intérêts c'est une question que
j'avais déjà posée au caire 20 ans je
m'excuse tout le temps parce que tout à
fait 18 ans et j'avais posé l'autre
question qui à la sélection des experts
dont on parle comme ça et j'avais dit
faites attention vous savez l'expert qui
avait été choisi à l'époque pour parler
du du charmant et à l'expert qui avait
été envoyé il servait d'experts
polyvalent cela il était que ces experts
polyvalent il venait de l'institut
pasteur et je suis expert alors j'avais
fait mois après ses publications j'ai
l'habitude de faire ça m'est experts de
rien du tout je dis mais c'est pas vrai
ce type s'est fait choper l'année
d'après pour vouloir passer chez nous
elle casse exceptionnel il avait
bidouiller son cv il avait doublé le
nombre de ses publications mais il y
avait un jeune qui avait regardé sur son
ordinateur sur pubmed des publications
elle est à moitié des publications que
vous avez mis là vous n'êtes pas dedans
d'accord et c'était le représentant que
pasteur nous envoyer à chaque fois le
pasteur le mineur en prêt mais ça veut
dire que les experts c'est quelque chose
il faut avoir une analyse neutre et pour
ça il faut je peins céréales et les
institutions dans ce pays il au leu leu
leu l'observatoire des sciences des
techniques qui sont parfaitement
compétents pour faire ça il faut leur
demander une évaluation de la qualité
des experts et il faut demander sur
transparence tant move
effectivement le fait que ce soit pas de
l'auto déclaration mais que les gens
n'aiment vraiment pas de conflit
d'intérêt pour la question dont il parle
si si si quelqu'un qui a travaillé à
gilead rue qu'a fait partie du board de
grillades parle de microscopie chronique
ça me gêne pas payé c'est pas le
problème mais si c'est pour parler du
rêve des civières ou ces pourparlers
truc ça me pose un problème et donc je
pense que c'est milton friedman qui dit
ça ou ça il n'y a pas de repas gratuits
mais si vous voulez on va passer aux
questions avec d'abord les orateurs pour
les groupes avec damien abad pour le
républicain
merci beaucoup madame le président le
professeur ce matin dans une interview
vous avez déclaré
dans ce pays on adore décapiter les gens
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu on
essaie de vous décapité et si oui
pourquoi et par qui
j'avais une question de professeurs
d'avoir sur les données de santé
publique france quand on regarde le
nombre de décès par million d'habitants
en france il a été 2 440 soit peu près
de 30000 personnes à marseille où vous
appliquez donc votre protocole le nombre
de décès par million d'habitants il a
été environ trois fois inférieur est-ce
que donc selon vous si on avait appliqué
et six gouvernements avaient appliqué ce
protocole partout en france
est ce que nous aurions pu sauver trois
fois plus de vie c'est à dire dix mille
10 personnes professeurs peron parle lui
de 25 mille personnes est-ce que vous
pouvez là dessus nous nous précise un
somme de choses et dernière question
c'est pour revenir sur les tests on a
bien compris
finalement la difficulté qu'ils avaient
et vous l'avez dit au conseil
scientifique est apparemment vous avez
part été entendus sur notamment le fait
que les tests étaient sur les cendres
d'un sur deux références est ce qu'il ya
eu des blocages volontaire est ce qu'on
considérait qu'à des blocages volontaire
de l'institut pasteur destination de
référence à ce qu'on n'était pas prêts
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui a fait que
finalement on n'a pas eu de politique de
dépistage massif comme vous l'avez fait
vous à marseille notamment dans les
ehpad mais aussi partout sur le
territoire
on a besoin selon de comprendre si vous
voulez vous avez dénoncé ce monopole là
est-ce que vous avez mis sur la da est
ce que vous en avez parler au président
de la république de ce monopole
et est ce que on aurait pu évoluer là
dessus est sûre je crois que pour
priorité je crois qu'on a évolué je
pense que le mieux la santé actuelle a
compris et qui l'a mis il a un objectif
est à mon sens ce qui aurait pu être
plus rapide mais je crois qu'il a
compris qu'il fallait faire énormément
de test et que c'était ça va dire ça
arrive maintenant ou c'est probablement
un peu maintenant il ya trop de cas
actuellement mais le débit est pas le
même que ce qu'il était au moment
on avait la vague et où il était
nécessaire ne serait-ce encore une fois
pour comprendre la maladie il faut en
faire le diagnostic
donc on peut pas envoyer désigner les
gens qui vont je vous donne un exemple
qui m'a beaucoup frappé il y a monsieur
chinois qu'avec 80 ans qui venait de la
zone dubai pas de l'uad d'accord qui
s'est présentée à la pitié salpêtrière
il y avait de la fièvre les 80 ans il
revenait de chine il n'a pas été testé
parce que santé publique a aidé il faut
tester que les gens de luan qui ont de
la fièvre et de la toux
il est entré chez lui et avait dû 7
jours après après avoir contaminé sa
fille il est venu mourir d'un hôpital
dans lequel on lui redonne du rnd ci
dira d'accord donc c'est ça c'est toute
l'histoire qui s'est passé quand même de
a à z et donc ça pose une question c'est
d'abord il ya une arrogance qui est de
savoir comment vont se présenter les
malades sur une maladie qu'on connaît
pas ça c'est pas bien d'accord et ça ça
a été justifiée par le fait qu'on peut
pas faire de test mais on peut pas faire
de test parce que moi au début on
m'interdit de plaintes est encore une
fois donc c'est jeu j'ai dit écoutez
vous en verrez les positif pour qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui soit meilleur que moi
faire la pcr qui face à la politique moi
je reçoive 10000 précédents événements
du monde pour faire les pcr monde entier
de la mayo clinic nasa chaussettes
généraux pital de long au monde entier
mais je ne pouvais pas faire en france
d'un moustique du coc vide
donc il ya quand même une réflexion il
arrête mais la réflexion encore une fois
il ya des choses qui sont des
responsabilités humaines directes et il
ya des choses qui sont structurels je
pense que si on maintient un système de
ses systèmes de petits centres nationaux
de référence
vous développerez des personnalités de
niche de blaireau dans leur terrier qui
montrent si on s'en approche
je pense que c'est comme ça c'est les
humains ils sont territoriaux et s'il
considère qu'une maladie et leur
territoire vous êtes perdus voilà je
vous le dis c'est comme ça parce que
c'est l'expérience de l'âge m'excuse
faut bien que ça serve à quelque chose
de vieillir et donc ça en tout cas je
sais ça si vous constituer des
territoires dans la république pour des
des problèmes généraux
vous aurez des difficultés considérables
je me rappelle qu'il faut poser question
une fois pas l'une après l'autre
donc ça rien à voir avec moment de
découvrir non c'était la question
c'était sur les nombre de vies sauvées
par rapport à votre protocole que vous
avez fait notamment et je ne peux pas
dire y ait un travail je ne sais pas
dire il ya un travail pour lequel nous
on a fait une opération grossière un qui
vient de d'être disponible à paris sur
le simplement le plaquer mills vous
voulez sur 4500 personnes on a comparé
hier je sais pas quoi 600 personnes qui
ont reçu du clac anil et puis les autres
qui n'ont pas reçu il ya une différence
de mortalité de 20 % maintenant on a
calculé que ça faisait 150 personnes
c'est ce que je sais les calculs de leur
donner à tout le monde c'est disponible
suite de regarder tes parmi les auteurs
il a beaucoup critiqué bofa la vie et
malicieuse c'est comme ça donc c'est
bien on verra bien sûr s'il arrive qu'on
se trompe mais il faut être pondérés
dans ses dents avant d'avoir la
connaissance de ce qui se passe pour le
bon il faut être pondérés dans l'ain
dans les commentaires avant pour pas se
faire rattraper par l'histoire donc en
pratique je ne sais pas il ya des choses
qui ne sont pas il ya deux éléments qui
me paraissent être des éléments
inquiétants dans cette question la
proportion voyez des gens qui sont morts
qu'en moins de 65 ans à paris sur les
données que j'ai de 17%
je vous rappelle que en europe elle est
de 10 % qui s'est passé quelque chose
ici sur la prise en charge la mortalité
dans les réanimations ici dans ce
travail toujours et de 43% chez nous
elle est de 16%
c'est les mêmes malades ils sont tous en
verre donc il ya quelque chose s'ils
voulaient il y a une à mon sens et c'est
une des vraies il ya de vrais problèmes
pour moi en dehors des phénomènes
structuraux pour lequel c'est pas des
questions d'individus c'est les
questions structure c'est de décider de
ne pas s'acharner sur le soin et donc le
soin est passée au second plan
et on a même vu effectivement des
interdictions du nuage de médicaments
qui sont génériques et qui ont été
distribués à des milliards de comprimés
puisque je vous rappelle que l'hydroxyde
eurokin ça a été publiée par quelqu'un
de la cnam en 2019
il était distribué 36 millions de
comprimés sans ordonnance et d'un coup
on décide
on n'a plus le droit du tout d'utiliser
ça donc il ya quelque chose donc celui
qui a aidé à décider de ça moi je vous
assure que lui l'a fait de faute et
après on demand même l'azithromycine on
peut plus donner ce nom au pâtis
suspecte de qu il attendait c'est le
médicament le plus utilisé n'est pas au
pâtis aux états unis on ne mangeait pas
ces données en france nées aux états
unis tous les ans il ya une personne sur
huit qui prend de l'asie trop me suis
donc pour transformer ces trucs en
poison violence voulait il faut avoir
quand même
alors bien sûr si vous utilisez des
doses déraisonnable mais c'est comme le
doliprane sait si vous doublez la dose
maximale ne doit pas vous pourrez quand
même
donc c'est des médicaments dangereux si
on les utilise pas à des posologies à
des ad des doses qui sont normales moi
j'utilise ça depuis 25 ans le placali
pour les maladies dont je suis
spécialisé à 600 mg par jour et on leur
donne pendant deux ans donc on fait des
dosages tous les mois c'est mais des
choses qu'on maîtrise donc si vous
voulez d'un coup vous nous dites que
c'est pour ça que quand le papier du
lendemain est est sorti lundi à 10 % de
morts
vous imaginez bien que je crois que les
10% de mort puisque nous on en était
déjà à 3000 personnes contre été avec ça
et j'avais moins avant sa tt 3000
personnes avec ça donc c'était pas
possible
600 morts qu'ils soient passées
inaperçues que j'ai pas vu moi je sais
combien il ya de morts parmi les gens
qui sont passés derrière lui en est mort
36 ans tous les chefs trois et moi c'est
pas des données de big data c'est des
vrais données de doctor who may regarder
on a ressorti le dossier on a fait des
autopsies verbale c'est de comprendre
quoi ils témoignent d'ailleurs 30% qui
était membre surinfections bactériennes
donc encore une fois ça je crois qu'il y
avait il ya appris ce débat a pris un
tour qui est tout à fait fantastique
n'était pas raisonnable et il y avait un
véritable problème c'est que les malades
c'est au docteur de les soigner c'est
pas une dérive qui est que de maintenant
un mois j'étais en désaccord déjà n'a
pour dire c'était on aller vacciner les
gens restent avec ses médecins
généralistes qui devait le faire on a on
a mis des années avant de remonter sur
la vaccination antigrippale à cause de
ça d'ailleurs on l'a dit au médecin
s'est plu à vous à faire ça vous savez
pas faire c'est nous qui allons faire
l'animation tirez pas donc l'idée que
l'état se saisisse de tâches qui sont du
soin usuelles si vous voulez à la place
des médecins et leur interdisent de
faire certaines choses qui sont pas là
je ne suis pas d'accord et pour le dire
d'ailleurs tout à fait officiellement je
suis surpris que l'ordre des médecins et
accepter une chose pareille moi si
j'avais été président de l'ordre des
médecins ses quatre gardes j'aurais
démissionné immédiatement parce que
c'est la responsabilité des médecins de
faire pour le mieux dans leur dans
l'état de leurs connaissances et
d'ailleurs quand propos si vous posez la
question quand nous avons décidé est
basé sur nos résultats de commencer à
l'utiliser ce à chaque médecin
individuellement dans le soin courant je
m'étais assuré auprès du directeur
général de la santé qui a bien compris
les choses de la même manière que moi et
bien sûr gels la trace de semaine les
médecins doivent faire pour le mieux
pour leurs malades en leur âme et
conscience compte tenu de notre état de
connaissances il y ait des privés de sa
est quelque chose qui pensant je ne sais
même pas si c'est constitution d âge je
me pose la question c'est vous qui savez
moi j'ai des doutes sur le fait même que
soit constitution merci patrick mignola
point madame merci le présidente sue
professeur dans le dans le travail de
notre commission
nous allons devoir analyser la
difficulté de la décision publique
face à la controverse scientifique et
vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure c'était
très intéressant que au fond c'est
normal en tout cas c'est pas insolite
qui nous soit permis ici de considérer
que c'est assez anormal quand on est en
période de crise parce que les français
ont découvert pendant deux mois sur leur
chaîne de télévision que le des médecins
ou des scientifiques préféré le
polémiquer ou s'opposer plutôt que se
convaincre et finalement ressembler des
hommes politiques dans ce que nous avons
moins bon donc la question
pourquoi j'ai entendu les conflits de
personne j'ai entendu les conflits
d'intérêts mais la question j'ai envie
de vous poser c'est comment on est vite
ça pour l'avenir encore une fois il ya
des phénomènes structurels je pense
qu'ils qui est que vous ne riez pas de
mon point de vue ce type de problème si
le le le vous aviez des sachants sans
conflit d'intérêt qui discutent entre
eux les vrais sa chambre le problème
c'est que et c'est un problème qui va
plus loin si vous pensez aux rebelles
moi j'ai depuis longtemps et comme ça ça
répondra aussi aussi à votre question à
laquelle pardon je n'ai pas répondu sur
les coupeurs de têtes ça répond à une
question le c'est une question d'hommes
s'étaient pas une question de régime
politique en 80 quand philippe lazare
été nommé président de l'inserm la
première chose qu'il a fait ses virées
les cinq personnes les plus connus en
france dans le domaine de la médecine
donc c'était en bourget le premier avoir
fait une greffe de rein monde c'était
mater qui a inventé le traitement du
cancer de la vessie par le bcg qu'on
utilise tout le temps d'accord c'était
dos et qui était le seul prix nobel en
exercice et il avait décidé qu'on
pouvait pas être directeur d'une unité
inserm plus de 12 ans et comme il avait
été plus de 12 ans alors qu'ils étaient
en cours de mandat il les a virés
d'accord donc quand on dit que lors de
tests pour ça comment j'ai été viré par
les lis je les dis d'ailleurs président
ça me fait faire partie d'un club dont
je pensais pas que j'avais le niveau
donc c'est des choses qui arrivent et ça
c'était un mouvement général de sortie
de l'inserm des hôpitaux alors que
l'inserm avait été créé pour faire de la
recherche médicale dans les hôpitaux
toutes les premières unités inserm était
dans les hôpitaux et donc ça a été un
mouvement de sortie de l'inserm des
hôpitaux donc il ya un vrai problème
c'est que l'inserm est majoritairement
en dehors des hôpitaux
alors qu'est ce qui reste dans les
hôpitaux il reste des cette réflexion
une réflexion très ancienne de la
recherche médicale qui n'est pas dans
les hôpitaux qui n'est pas qu'ils
manquent d'organisation donc le
législateur avait prévu avec la d2 art
les formes de mairie que vous votez tous
les ans basée sur des critères qui pour
une fois sont des critères objectifs des
biométrique s'appelle les six gardes
mais quand vous votez ça en réalité ça
ne va pas du tout là où vous l'avez
voter parce que on a oublié de mettre un
arrêté sur la non fongibilité de ce
budget donc vous donner un budget pour
faire la recherche mais en réalité le
conseil administration fait ce qu'il
veut il fait pas de recherche break et
une rampe à 30
il n'a pas de comptes à rendre sur
l'utilisation d'un argent que vous avez
voté pour faire des recherches
donc il n'y a pas d'argent pour faire la
recherche sauf de faire la recherche
majeurs les hôpitaux d'accord est la
troisième source de financement c'est
celle sur laquelle revient c'est celle
de l'industrie pharmaceutique qui est un
budget de financement pourraient garder
aussi d'un euro fort knox qui est égal
au volume complet du budget de l'inserm
d'accord et vous avez une agence
spécifique sur le sida et des hépatites
si fait que vous si vous regardez moi
j'ai regardé la la la production
scientifique qui se passe en tout et
pour tout chez les gens qui sont
spécialistes en maladies infectieuses
dans 70 à 75% des cas représentent
seulement le sida les hépatites les
antibiotiques et vous avez 25 % pour
tout le reste donc pour trouver des
sachants dans le reste ce domaine là
c'est extrêmement difficile
donc si vous n'avez pas de sa chance et
si vous n'avez pas un niveau de
financement autonome de la recherche
dans les hôpitaux comme c'est prévu par
la loi mais comme cela n'est pas
appliqué
vous n'aurez pas la recherche que nous
méritons je me suis exprimé à plusieurs
reprises as-tu c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle d'ailleurs directeur de
l'inserm et elle était très hostile
c'est parce que je je dis ce que je
pense je vois pas pour je le dirai pas
c'est à dire que si vous voulez vous ne
pouvez pas peut-être que vous souhaitez
samoa nombre bonjour je crois comme
michel foucault que la vie sociale et à
la guerre s'est vite donc on se dispute
parce que pour faire avancer les choses
donc on peut pas éviter quand les choses
vont mal d'avoir des conflits entre nous
parce qu'elles vont mal et donc le fait
que l'on se dispute c'est le témoin du
fait que les choses ne vont pas bien et
donc si elles ne vont pas bien c'est
effectivement qu'il y allait problème de
fond est que les acteurs qui sont la
torre de ça sont des acteurs moi je
encore une fois j'ai pensé j'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises
faire tourner en permanence autour de ça
moi je pense que de dangers et est ce
que ce que hegel appelle les russes de
la raison c'est à dire que au bout d'un
moment la raison s'exprime par les
humains j'appelle ça les héros je ne
crois pas être un héros héros fictif
si vous voulez l'utiliser les humains
pour faire émerger le problème un
problème de raison qui n'a pas été
résolu par un accident qui permet de
mettre à plat encore une fois je ne vous
dis pas que j'ai raison j'ai écrit ça ya
vingt ans je le pense encore dont je
joue
moi je suis stable dont m l'union
européenne je n'ai pas était démentie de
mon point de vue par effet que j'ai été
capable d'observer voilà mais je les ai
peut-être pas tous vivants mais donc le
problème n'est pas résolu et donc le
problème reviendra
et donc si vous refaites un groupe en
dire écoutez pour faire la recherche
médicale on va prendre les gens de
l'inserm et puis les gens de pasteur et
puis vont se partager les la manière de
réfléchir et c'est eux qui vont gérer le
problème des hôpitaux je vous le dis + 2
ou 3 personnes qui travaillent avec
industries pharmaceutiques et
exclusivement je vous le dis merci boris
vallot merci mon âme est présidente
merci professeur pour les premiers les
premiers éléments on a un peu de mal à
cerner la place exacte qu'il avoue dans
la gestion de la crise vous avez été
membre éphémère du conseil scientifique
et ce serait intéressant de savoir quels
ont été les les votre participation lors
des premiers échanges je crois que vous
êtes là jusqu'au jusqu'au deuxième
jusqu'au deuxième mali vous avez reçu le
président emmanuel macron début début
horrible eu des conversations avec lui
il a d'ailleurs reconnu que saisissant
des tests vous y étiez
visionnaire sur la nécessité de les
modifier
vous avez dit à plusieurs reprises que
vos contacts avec le président de la
république et avec eux le ministre de la
santé avait été régulier que d'ailleurs
s'agissant de la décision d'ouvrir les
écoles peut être vous avez inspiré la
décision du président de la république
j'aimerais savoir précisément en quoi
vous considérez avoir été écouté et a
contrario en quoi vous considérez ne pas
avoir été écouté et je crois que c'est
un peu le sentiment que vous avez
exprimées parfois dans la presse a cessé
la première
question moi j'ai oublié ma deuxième
question sinon c'est le problème des
parlementaires qui pose trois ou quatre
questions déjà posées gens pensent que
je vais leur dire une après l'autre
bon d'accord oui oui le professeur cissé
la présidente m'autorise à reprendre la
parole après bon voilà avec le président
veut pas bousculer vos rythmes et je
préférais il répondu à l'appel autres
comme ça je pense avoir écouté j'ai
senti j'ai pensé peut-être que je me
trompe mais si vous voulez c'est surtout
à moi-même que je rendais compte donc
j'ai essayé d'avoir les cimes de
moi-même d'edf 1 d'accord avec moi mais
c'est ce que je sais faire donc j'ai
pensé que je pourrais être utile dans
cette crise parce que je crois que j'ai
une expérience qui est extrême dans ce
domaine là et j'ai essayé de le faire à
chaque fois comme je pouvais il se
trouve que dans ce conseil scientifique
j'ai été un ovni
donc je m'en fous un extraterrestre donc
y avait pas de compatibilité génétique
entre nous c'était pas possible c'est un
groupe qui se connaissaient entre eux
qu'ils travaillaient depuis des années
ensemble c'était le groupe reacting
inserm et donc là dedans je suis arrivée
là dedans ce jeu je pense que c'est le
président qui a souhaité que je fasse
partie de ce groupe
donc je suis arrivée seconde errements
dans un groupe de gens qui travaillent
ensemble qui avait 10 des très précises
qui avait déterminé ce qu'il fallait
faire avant que j'arrive et je n'étais
pas d'accord
par exemple encore une fois il y avait
deux molécules dont on pensait qu'elle
pouvait être efficace je pensais que si
on devait faire un effet il fallait
faire les séries télé de mon lit tout ça
me paraissait raisonnable
donc j'ai vu que je n'arrivais pas on
nous n'arrivions pas à parler donc je ne
vais pas voulu mais j'ai continué à
penser que je pouvais être utile je
crois que c'est ce qu'a pensé le
président et je pense que d'une certaine
manière c'est ce qu'a pensé aussi le le
ministre faut dire à chaque fois que
nous nous avons trouvé quelque chose
j'en ai toujours informé le ministre
avant d'en parler publiquement toujours
d'accord lui ou son compte ou un de ses
conseillers qui avec qui je j'ai des
rapports tout à fait fonctionnel et
raisonnable donc oui effectivement le le
président macron je pense qu'ils étaient
d'accord avec le fait qu'il fallait
testé massivement
deuxièmement je lui ai montré le début
de la version de la courbe qui nous
permettait de d'évaluer si les choses se
passaient comme on a l'habitude pour les
courbe en cloche de voir que les choses
s'arrêtent atteindrait un niveau
vraiment minimale minimale en mai je lui
ai montré j'étais le premier aussi c'est
un débat jeudi 20h et enfants n'a pas
non plus très peu ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure
delfraissy a dit oui mais un acquis
d'ici à 10 h 10 montre moi ceux qui
disent pas ça et moi j'ai sorti le
papier que je venais de faire sur le
dosage les enfants commis avec moi
qu'elle va garder les enfants avec moi
qui n'en paient savait donc c'est le
niveau qu'on avait si vous voulez de
discussion 6 à windham et toi tu dis ça
et l'autre dit ça mais jamais avec les
papiers sur la table jamais avec des
données sur la table et je ne travaille
pas comme ça je suis pas un homme de
réunion un homme de données je suis
content d'être ici mais c'est pas ma
nature
le manager c'est de travailler sur les
données j'aime créer des données j'aime
avoir les données pour pouvoir réfléchir
et donc mais et je peux même vous dire
j'espère que ça ne fera pas appel mais
je lui ai dit qu'il fallait parce qu'il
n'y a pas grand monde qui se souvenaient
de cette chose là qu'il fallait
ressusciter la médaille des epide c'est
moi qui ai dit et je pense qu'il va le
faire je pense qu'il fait bien parce que
dans une épidémie à un dévouement
absolument hallucinant il ya des gens
qui se révèle et qu'il faut reconnaître
l'effort qu'ils ont fait que la
république doit le reconnaître et que ce
n'est pas nécessairement par l'ordre du
mérite ou lors de la légion d'honneur
mais par le phénomène
et donc vous voyez qu'il ya plus de
choses dont nous avons parlé qui ont des
conséquences et je vous dis moi les
premières données que nous avons eues
sur les séquelles je leur en ai parlé ce
matin encore je peux le temps de vous en
parler on trouve des séquelles sur le
vous savez qu'un décines qui avaient été
négligés qui dessine très très important
c'est la perte de l'odorat en
particulier chez les gens de moins de 50
ans et qui va plutôt avec des formes pas
grave
la perte de l'odorat et du goût enfin le
bout c'est une complexité telle doha
c'est plus simple et les gens s'en
souviennent très bien et nous quand on
fait maintenant on a fait les sérologies
dans le dos de personnel on les
interrogeait en même temps on a
interrogé trois mille personnes pour
l'odorat le goût l'odorat les gens
peuvent vous dire oui de tel jour à
telle jours je me sentais plus et c'est
une valeur prédictive que l'on appelle
une valeur prédictive de 66% dans 66%
des cas quand vous allez être positif
vous avez moins de 50 ans vous avez une
perte de l'odorat
c'est très très important très très fort
comme test chez ces gens ces études que
nous avons en cours actuellement il à
30% qui n'ont pas récupéré leur doit et
maintenant on est en train de faire un
travail qui online qui a été fait par le
professeur guedj qui nous a présenté sa
mardi quand on regarde par pet scan qui
est une manière d'analyser le cerveau on
voit que le cerveau olfactif le cerveau
qui perçoit les odeurs qui est juste au
dessus des sinus a donc c'est une vraie
proximité et ne fonctionne moins bien
c'est ce qu'on appelle un
hypométabolisme et que ça peut s'étendre
ça en arrière de ça et toucher 1
la concentration certain déséquilibre et
2 la mémoire et il y a des gens qui
actuellement se plaignent d'avoir des
troubles de la concentration des
troubles de la mémoire comme séquelle et
c'est toujours comme vous le savez très
très difficile les données subjectives
et peu mesurable de voir si elles sont
affectées ou pas et là on a des outils
et je peux vous dire ça j'ai téléphoné
hier pour le dire
mystère la santé regardez voilà les
premières données qu'on a sur les
séquelles possibles comme j'avais
téléphoné pour dire écoutez voilà dans
les scans low dose on voit maintenant
temps pour cent de fibrose les gens qui
sont partis en relation donc j'ai tout
le temps tout ce que j'aurais dû
transmettre au conseil scientifique
ça c'est de la science je l' ai transmis
directement et à l'elysée et au
ministère la santé tout le temps et donc
il n'y a rien de nouveau je n'ai annoncé
que je n'ai annoncé avant les autorités
de tutelle ce que sa réponse à votre
question
alors si lui permettre de poser la
question qu'est ce qui selon vous n'avez
pas été entendu ou écouter de la part de
l'exécutif ou des autorités de gestion
et qui aurait eu des conséquences
défavorables
[Musique]
essayez de de jeu le prolonger ce que ce
que vous avez vous allez lire c'est si
on m'avait écouté il y aurait eu moins
de morts il concrètement vous pensez à
quoi
si vous voulez je pense que il a été
tenté de faire une vraie régulation de
l'hydro de cycle en chine avec l'asie
trop micinn mais la mise en place de sa
a été tardive et que donc le test mais
il n'y a aucune évaluation décès du tout
qui a été mis en place dans son conseil
scientifique c'est une faillite totale
rien du tout rien et il y arrivera
peut-être quelque chose mais quand il y
aura plus de cas donc ça devrait vous
faire réfléchir sur le degré
d'efficacité
si vous voulez de ce type de stratégie
si quelqu'un vous n'arrivez pas avoir de
résultats du tout ça vous faites au
cours d'une épidémie quand l'épidémie
est finie vous n'avez pas et les
réalisations même pas disponibles moi je
serais content d'avoir les résultats de
recovery devoir de les analyser moi même
papa pas d'attendre qu'on trouve les
analyser ma place parce que encore une
fois la manière des alizés est une
manière de 2,2 d'approuver s'approprier
les résultats bruts
donc c'est pas ma faute si non c'est pas
organiser les essais dans ce pays g donc
quand même ça c'est factuel encore une
fois est qu'à regarder si vous avez vous
des résultats de la connerie je suis
content pour moi je les ai pas et dans
un certain nombre de cas je pense que
c'était même pas réalisable s'il ya des
gens qui voulaient inclure des malades
il n'y a pas d'âme sivir d'accord j'en
ai pas et il n'y avait pas de disponible
parce qu' il n'était pas magnifique
d'accord donc tout ça cette obsession
moi j'ai vu depuis le début de d'essayer
de traiter gens avec leur ai dit si vous
voulez est quelque chose qui est de
toute manière ne mener rien parce que
même s'ils avaient réussi à montrer
qu'il ya quelque chose de toute manière
on aurait pas de médicaments maintenant
parce qu'on n'a pas encore et donc il
faut se poser la question de savoir si
ça c'était vraiment purement du jeu
boursier est ce que c'était juste pour
faire monter la valeur de gilead avant
la fusion avec astrazeneca à ce que
c'était ça
l'objectif parce que de toute manière
les médicaments ne l'aurait pas vu donc
il y a il ya une question de fond qui à
là question contre la gale moi je me
bats que je ne comprends pas enfin où je
ne veux pas à comprendre quand je veux
pas l'exprimer
merci monsieur lagarde pour lui dit oui
merci me présidente monsieur le
professeur avait prévu parce que je
n'aime pas ce qui est irrationnel ou
excessives comme les médias vous l'avez
dit vous-même que c'est passé très au
delà de la raison j'avais prévu de pas
vous vous interrogez sur sur votre
traitement mais m2 chose qui me viennent
à l'esprit où je ne parviens pas à
comprendre c'est pourquoi est ce que les
études que vous avez faites vous même en
même temps que vous soignez évidemment
c'est toujours comme ça qu'on fait des
études
vous n'avez pas souhaité les randomisés
pour permettre d'éteindre les
contestations de toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ont contesté entre guillemets
vos résultats et dans le sens inverse
est-ce que vous avez une rave l'idée
d'une raison qui fait que quand vous
dénoncez dans le parisien je crois quand
on teste votre traitement en fait on
respecte jamais votre posologie ce qui
est une aberration parce que s'ils
respectent pas la posologie d'un
traitement c'est pas la peine de dire
qu'on a été étudié ces résultats voilà
c'est quand même de questions qui après
dans d'autres interventions il ya quand
même
oui bien sûr si tu sais c'est
intéressant mais si vous regardez sur le
le site ne croyait pas du tout qu'on a
commencé à m online nos réflexions et
nos cours augmente du coronavirus on
avait commencé bien avant mais il se
trouve que le gros navires us à
amplifier le phénomène et que vous
l'avez vu qu'à ce moment là mais donc on
faisait une fois par semaine je m'excuse
on appelait ça on a le droit d'être
intelligent parce qu'on pensait que les
médias rapportaient une déformation de
la connaissance que nous avions que donc
on avait besoin d'exprimer nous mêmes
directement sur ce que nous savions nous
croyons savoir faut faut être prudent et
nous avions fait on fait des jeux dits
de les hacher thématiques dont un très
précisément deux mois avant le début de
l'essor du coronavirus était sur la
méthode d'accord quelles sont les
méthodes d'analysé qu'est ce que c'est
que l'historique de la méthode c'est de
l'épistémologie vous pouvez le voir
c'est toujours online s'appelle contre
la méthode comment est-ce que 11
sa compagne mais la méthode ce qui est
une véritable question est encore une
fois le rite delà de la randomisation
des grands essais thérapeutiques
multicentrique d'un phénomène
extrêmement récents dans la science il y
a je pense dans les maladies
infectieuses moins de 5% des traitements
maladies infectieuses actuellement qui
sont basées sur des essais randomisés en
double donc c'est peut-être parce que je
suis plus vieux ou parce que je suis
hérétiques au sein seulement
étymologique que je ne me laisse pas
impressionner par le fait que l'on dise
maintenant c'est la doxa ça ne
m'impressionne pas donc je le pense les
effets bien il ya si on s'y intéresse
sur la littérature de la part de la
prescience et que l'on comparé les
effets randomisés aux essais comparatifs
historique les essais randomisés sont
plutôt moins performants que les essais
comparatifs historique donc c'est
d'ailleurs tous les gens qui critiquait
sa cousine publie maintenant des essais
qui ne sont que purement comparatif donc
si vous voulez c'est intéressant que ça
ne s'applique à moi ça parce que quand
même tous les essais qui sont publiés ne
seront publiés caufriez dernier et deux
décès qui ont été publiés par les
parisiens ne sont que des essais qui
sont non randomisé y en a 2 0 en france
d'accord donc c'est juste pour moi je
suis parano visée parce que je suis
agréable je ne suis pas bon je me trompe
pas désagréable devant je le trouve
plutôt et par llorente et c'est un privé
un point de vue qui est très subjectif
et deuxièmement la randomisation est un
phénomène qui est un phénomène un espèce
de standard qui est très asocial
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui ne me
convainc pas donc ce que nous on fait ça
à l'essai comparatif
à la différence des autres enfin vrai
effet comparatif puisque on a comparé
les gens de nice avec les gens de
marseille et légendes nice ne prenait
pas avec un hard comme qui était très
clair et qu'on était les seuls à pouvoir
employer
c'est à dire une mesure qui était très
critique était simple qui était la
persistance ou la non persistance du
virus en réclamant d'accord donc c'est
ça notre premier papier c'est très
simple ces sujets valcke anglais on sait
j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup d'études
dans la vie beaucoup de traitement et
donc on dit voilà deux groupes
on regarde chez lesquels le virus
disparaît le premier il se trouve qu est
venue se greffer un troisième groupe
puisque l'on comparé les drogues
cycloclean ehpad identique
hockin est venue se greffer un troisième
groupe qui est chez nous les gens qui
étaient plus graves on les traite comme
les infections virales sévère en
rajoutant bazille trop meeting on s'est
rendu compte qu'en rajoutant de l'az et
romy si en même temps on était en train
de la tester au laboratoire en
association et séparément des droitiers
claudine le nombre de virus dit bill est
beaucoup plus rapidement donc on avait
une fois qu'on avait ces données on a
fait des tests statistiques samedi
montré que c'était différent a publié ce
papier qui n'a pas posé de problème de
publication et d'un coup ça déchaîné
influent que je n'imaginais pas et
d'ailleurs encore une fois la question
et si vraiment les gens déjà écouté non
mais il ya un premier papier mais on
doute vraiment scientifiquement on refus
et puis on regarde et donc pourquoi
est-ce que là personne n'a fait ça
donc là je m'excuse de maintenant il ya
une série de 4500 personnes qui est
passé à paris là qui est de sortir
personne à fait différent de viser
personne vous voyez et il ya une je peux
même vous dire plus et les choses qui
m'ont sidéré il est sorti une première
étude faite par des en france dans
lequel il y avait un groupe sur lequel
il y avait identique leur kiné
azithromycine qui a été publiée dans le
british medical journal
et en ce groupe il y avait seize
personnes zéro passe en rien ses romans
et les auteurs ont refusé de faire le
test de base de significativité pour
montrer que c'était différent des autres
groupes et c'était l'hiver et ils n'ont
pas publié d'accord chance ailleurs mais
j'ai une opinion que je vous dirai pas
voir je vais je n'en sais rien
merci non c'est pas fini manager déféré
à la demande du professeur raoul
prétexte était que les méthodologies ce
10 ski études ce qui qui vous fera
comprendre pourquoi on peut pas
s'entendre
les méthodologies se disent qu'ils n'ont
pas le droit d'analyser des choses
qu'ils n'ont pas décidé d'analyser avant
de commencer ce qui est le principe de
l' inverse découverte et donc ils ont
dit à ça alors que c'était le traitement
qu'ils aient le planète ça on n'a pas
décidé avant de commencer l'étude de
l'analyse et donc on ne la laisse pas
même si c'est significatif merci je vais
vous demandez pas posé de questions
entre deux parce que là c'est monsieur
lagarde qui veut à paroles et le fait de
poser des questions intermédiaires et
parasites
se dire ça empêche les bonnes la bonne
compréhension des questions réponses
même si quelquefois il faut y revenir
alors monsieur lagarde allez-y merci à
la présidente professeur il ya deux
autres choses qui me frappe la première
c'est que à travers tout d'autres
interventions vous êtes en train de nous
les convois et de le décrire un monde de
conflit d'intérêts ou d'intérêt
absolument puissant y compris lorsque
vous avez quitté le conseil scientifique
vous avez abordé le conseil scientifique
vous avez dit que je vais être pas assez
de temps pour passer à participer à des
couillonnades et dans le même temps vous
nous expliquer que finalement ces gens
là travaillent entre eux et qu'on avait
qu'à regarder où étaient les conflits
d'intérêts ce que dit le journal
marianne d'ailleurs par ailleurs dans un
article récent moi j'aurais aimé que
nous en dit plus là dessus parce que
vous pouvez pas nous mettre sur une
piste
l'objectif comme l'a dit la présidente
c'est quand même de trouver comment ça
ne se reproduit pas donner des pistes
sur les centres de référence etc
mais comment diriger il faut quand même
qu'on sache un peu où sont les lièvres à
soulever pour éviter que ça puisse se
reproduire
et d'ailleurs si vous avez décrit un
certain nombre de choses vous avez
peut-être me parler de la place du
secrétariat général à la défense
nationale pendant la crise et pas dans
la préparation de la crise et dernier
point j'ai été frappé dans l'article du
parisien je crois encore que vous ayez
dit qu'il vous paraissait improbable que
nous puissions obtenir un vaccin
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi ce virus là
pour enfin il ya des virus non pas de
vaccin mais pourquoi celui-ci qui paraît
plus simple quand on lit des choses
qu'on n'est pas médecin ni candidat ni
rien pourquoi ça vous semble improbable
de trouver un vaccin alors sélections
jeu je pense comme toi je vous le dis je
veux je pense je sais pas ça fera partie
de votre enquête parlementaire moi je
vous recommande de faire une véritable
enquête sur gilead rn10 hier si vous
regardez la structure de gilead vous
comprendrez que c'est quelque chose qui
ne fonctionne qu'avec très très peu de
produits très peu de personnel et une
influence considère donc l'essentiel de
sa stratégie basée sur l' influence
moi j'ai été quand même je vous le
rappelle moi quand j'ai commencé à
parler pour la première fois la
chloroquine ya quelqu'un qui m'a menacé
à plusieurs reprises manière anonyme
j'ai porté plainte et j'ai fini par
trouver que c'était celui qui avait reçu
le plus d'argent de wilaya depuis six
ans d'accord
donc si vous voulez j'ai d une
expérience personnelle d'accord de
fonctionnement qui ne me paraissent pas
normaux peut-être que c'est une
coïncidence mais c'est pas sûr parce
qu'il me disait qui m'interdisait de
parler de claude d'accord chez les mails
j'ai porté plainte officiellement la
police on sait qui c'est d'accord donc
le niveau de problème là est un niveau
de problème sur lequel moi je vous
suggère d'être attentif
c'est pas compliqué de regarder encore
une fois qu'il ya des conflits intérêts
vont vers des listings au regard des
listings chez les infectiologues vous
regarde et on a même publié un article
là dessus pour dire écoutez les deux
tiers et on a même fait un article
malicieux en en regardant les gens qui
s'est exprimé dans la presse pour ou
contre la chloroquine et on a match et
ça avec le nombre d'argent qu'ils
avaient reçu de de guilers et c'est
parfaitement match et que je ne dis pas
la causalité et la corrélation sont deux
choses différentes
donc je dis pas qu'il ya une causalité
une coïncidence au sens étymologique
donc cesser la même incidence d'être
contre la chloroquine et de recevoir
l'argent de guilad donc je vous suggère
très fortement de poser la question de
savoir le niveau
moi je n'avais jamais vu d'un flux ans
d'une seule compagnie sur le
fonctionnement qui mon sens inclus dans
le monde des choses qui sont bien au
delà de celle du médiator donc ça
existait déjà
ça avait quand même donc existait déjà
là pour cet enjeu là ces a pris une
ampleur qui voit là et des rapports
s'étaient développées entre ce groupe
acting et gilead pour la tentative
d'utiliser 10 sieverts qui a été un
échec pour ebola ça n'a pas marché mais
ce groupe s'était formé au déjà autour
de ça et donc il ya des liens multiples
et pour pour aller jusqu'au bout des
choses moi j'ai été surpris de voir que
le directeur de gilead devant le
président a répliqué devant le ministre
tutoyer celui qui était en charge des
essais thérapeutiques en france pour
coville 19 quand même c'est lui moi j'ai
pas l'habitude de me faire tutoyer par
le directeur de l'industrie
pharmaceutique s'il faisait un jeu en
répondant le vouvoyant
ferai pas oui donc je pense qu'il ya des
jeux pour vous d'y arrêter je sais même
pas si ça n'est que des liens d'intérêts
je vous dis pas que les gens ont été
achetés pour sa légende créer un
écosystème encore une fois qui est un
écosystème favorable dans lequel la
vision qu'on a du monde est différente
et donc je pense que c'est ces relations
de familiarité ou de départ ensemble de
voyage ensemble amène à une vision et à
un écosystème qui est d'une nature à
permettre à changer le jugement des
choses je crois ça et je n'ai pas
d'exemple contraire j'ai vu ça à mon
époque moi quand j'étais jeune et ça
c'était les antibiotiques et donc je me
rappelle je peux faire ça du tout parce
qu'ils avaient une croisière qui a été
organisée par un médicament qui a
disparu maintenant s'appelle la paix
place in où il y avait 700 médecins qui
avaient été invités vous savez que les
premières règles de sur la déclaration
obligatoire des liens d'intérêts a été
faite après que maire qui a invité tous
les médecins de france aller en chine
pour des congrès factice tous d'accord
et c'est la conquête est mis en place
l'obligation de déclaration de l'ia ou
de financement auprès du conseil de
leurs professeurs sur le sur le vaccin
ces personnes je pourrais parler
autrement aussi
sur le vaccin si vous voulez moi
j'entends j'entends bien que qu'à chaque
fois qu'un nouveau virus si un nouveau
vaccin qui va arriver etc mais si vous
regardez là aussi je vous suggère de
regarder c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
bien qu'ils aient une erreur que je vais
vous rectifié vaut garder d'en avaler
ball vaccine de belles choses que veut
dire quels sont les vaccins disponibles
sur le site de l'om est ce vous regardez
et vous regarderez s'il ya et puis après
il ya tous les vaccins mais maintenant
ça c'est les possibles dans le vrai est
dans le vrai il ya deux faux d'ailleurs
ils disent qu'il ya vaccin pour le
paludisme ce qui est pas vrai vous
pouvez pas acheter un vaccin sur le
palier et ils disent qu'ils aillent
vaccin sur l'hépatite e ce qui est pas
vrai il y en a qu'un qui est a commencé
à développer en chine donc et vous
regardez si là dedans il ya beaucoup de
vaccins qui ont moins de 30 ans et vous
verrez et puis vous vous poserez la
question en tout cas moi je me pose
c'est pourquoi en france on fait pas la
vaccination contre la varicelle ya
plusieurs centaines milliers de cas ont
fait pas le vaccin contre le rotavirus
ont fait pas le vaccin contre la grippe
chez les enfants qui tue des enfants
d'accord et donc ça veut dire que
l'implantation des vaccins ensuite le
vaccin ça devient ensuite un problème
politique sociale et donc le degré la
capacité de que nous avons eu 30
dernières années à faire des vaccins qui
seront implantés et complexe et elle va
être encore plus complexe avec les
courants la vie est de mon point de vue
bien que j'en connaisse pas l'issue
parce que nous avons depuis une
expérience de la dengue ou la dengue est
un des seuls nouveaux vaccins il s'est
trouvé que la dengue chez les gens qui
n'avaient pas eu de dengue est exposé à
faire des dingues plus sévère que chez
les gens qui n'avaient pas été vaccinés
et on savait ça le deuxième épisode de
dengue est très sévère de l'eau les
hémorragies et donc si vous n'avez pas
d'une protection vous faites une dingue
banale si vous l'avez déjà fait une
dingue ou si elle fait un vaccin
eh bien vous faites une mite dengue
sévère et c'était une très mauvaise
surprise est ce une des raisons pour
lesquelles les philippines en
particulier on
attaquent les gens qui est vaccinée donc
c'est pas si simple que ça va merci
monsieur penchèrent oui ce professeur à
la controverse sur la chloroquine n'en
serait peut-être pas arriver là si comme
vous le soulignez on n'était pas un des
rares pays en france où c'est le
ministre de la santé qui dit comment
soigner en utilisant tel ou tel
médicament lors que partout ailleurs
sont les médecins qui sont libres de
prescrire en fonction de ce qu'ils ont
appris
votre intervention il ya quelques
instants c'est un ode à la révolution
girondine
c'est à dire 7 mettre fin cette
centralisation dans beaucoup de domaines
et notamment dans le domaine et
notamment dans le domaine de la santé
alors moi je veux revenir sur la
question des tests on est en avril
on teste pas août est peu sauf
évidemment chez vous ça commence les
français découvrent médusés que il ya
des tests dans les pays qui nous
entourent
on est mieux on est en avril il ya des
tas de laboratoire qui se tournent les
pouces et qui demandent qu'à tester et
comment est on teste pas et on teste pas
la france n'a commencé à mener des
campagnes de détection massive que mi
avril alors que l'italie et l'allemagne
disposent et de tests en nombre
suffisant début début avril nous on
teste à partir de mi mai il aurait fallu
sept cent mille tests dans notre pays
dès début avril pendant le pic de
l'équipe l'épidémie mais sa part été le
cas vous êtes un des rares exemples de
laboratoire ou prenez en main à travers
150 mille tests effectués est-ce qu'il
en a pas été avec les tests comme avec
les masques
nous n'avions pas suffisamment mais
comme nous n'étions pas organisés pour
en acquérir et en distribuer en
distribuer on a expliqué en plus dès le
début de la crise que ça serve ariane
tester tous nos dispositifs de gestion
test est concentré et vous l'avez
indiqué c'est qu'à partir de début avril
qu'on se rend enfin compte qu'il faut
tester massivement les pouvoirs publics
incitent à leur vécu et partout des
tests poussés sait où c'est possible
alors je voulais revenir sur le
professeur froguel qui est au chu de
lille et qui vit dans l'histoire des
tests ou mondement les directeurs
d'hôpitaux emmanuel macron passant par
la direction générale de la santé et
olivier vers ans partagez vous ce
sentiment sur l'absence de transparence
et la cacophonie et est ce que vous
pouvez répondre très précisément à cette
simple question combien de temps avons
nous perdu à peu près et combien de
morts on aurait pu éviter
encore une fois je
à part sur cette chose qui est assez
simple puisqu'il ya on rapporte 4500
personnes qui ont été hospitalisées à
paris et que l'on voit qu'il ya 20% de
moins en demeure avec roxy chloroquine
on peut calculer manière relativement
simple peut-être fausse parce que trop
simple qu'on met à mort pour la ccc
complexe je suis d'accord froger par
exemple avait écrit que lui pouvait
faire le millier de pcr par jour et que
sa direction le interdit de le faire
donc il y avait le fait de il y a eu un
mécanisme qui s'est fait dont je sais
pas comment il s'est fait mais il ya eu
un mécanisme qui s'est fait ces
puisqu'on peut pas faire les tests les
tests sont inutiles et c'était l'idée
qu'on pouvait pas faire était ce n'était
pas vrai et donc cette idée de on peut
pas faire les tests est une idée qui est
à la fois une idée de monopole une idée
de ça va être compliqué une idée de
ouvrons à 2 les réactifs
voilà moi je sais que par exemple pour
les extractions on utilise parmi les
machines qu'on utilise y en a une qui
est des plus utilisés qui est une
machine qui s'appelle qiagen qui
fabrique des réactifs en allemagne et
aux etats unis
et je sais qu'aux états unis ils auront
tout de suite interdit l'exportation de
tous les réactifs qui agit toujours
leurs mains parce qu'ils ont dit en
situation de crise on les veut tous
partent aux puces de relativement tôt
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya des positions
si vous voulez c'est pour ça encore une
fois ça revient cette question moi
c'était aussi une des choses dont
j'avais discuté avec le président j'ai
dit je pense que d'une crise cette
nature doit être gérée par le secrétaire
national de
la défense nationale parce que j'avais
vu que quand moi j'étais au ministère de
santé que celui qui était plus
raisonnable c'est lui parmi tous les
directeurs parce que quand j'étais en
plus et directeur et discuter entre eux
et donc il y avait quatre versions
successives qui arrivait au sgdn si vous
voulez parce que directeur était pas
d'accord donc simple et complexe neuf
ans quand même donc il faut un moment le
donneur d'ordre c'est le responsable de
la sécurité publique c'est mon avis
serait le temps je suis d'accord avec
vous que la sécurité publique ne devrait
pas jusqu'à interdire aux médecins et
aux pharmaciens de distribuer des
médicaments qui ont fait la preuve de
leur innocuité depuis 80 ans et je vais
vous donner une anecdote parce que
j'adore l'histoire
peut-être que vous savez passe à
l'histoire de la chloroquine ça remonte
très loin ça vient du pérou où ça vient
du quinquennat et il ya eu un drame
similaire sous louis xiv pour savoir si
l'on pouvait ou ne pouvait pas prendre
le quinquina et donc louis xiv qui
faisait des fièvre récurrente a fini par
prendre du kakina en public et donc à
partir du moment où il a pris du kakina
on public et bien le quinquina y rentrer
la pharmacopée française et il a fini
par de la quinine et puis la
chlorophylle et puis hydroxyque rouquine
qui sont tous les enfants du quinquina
ce médicament des plantes
merci caroline chat
merci monsieur le professeur d'études
recouvrit affirmerait que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine n'aurait pas d'efficacité
avérés contre lakovic 19 de mémoire vous
affirmez vous même il ya quelques
semaines que l'efficacité n'était pas
encore prouvée mais vous défendiez tout
de même la prescription de cette
molécule
car les premiers résultats de vos
recherches s'avérer concluant et que ses
effets secondaires étaient connus
comment juger cette nouvelle étude
aujourd'hui de nombreux rebondissements
que connaissent les déclarations faites
au sujet de la plus rock in rendent
particulièrement complexe attitude avoir
en termes de politique de santé et donc
je vais prendre exprès l'exemple de
l'essai clinique discovery qui a été
entre guillemets jeu mais bien des
guillemets opposé à votre essai et donc
on nous a annoncé qu'il avait échoué
par faute comment parce que les autres
pays européens ne sont pas entrées dans
l'essai clinique mais beaucoup de
soignants dont moi avons été étonnés
qu'il ne soit pas qu'il n'ait pas
échouer car selon la voie
d'administration et selon la posologie
même une aide-soignante pouvait très
vite deviner quels traitements donnés
aux patients et on sait très bien que
dans un essai clinique on n'est pas
censé savoir ce qu'on donne à nos
passions donc ces épisodes ces épisodes
successifs montrent à quel point les
enjeux de pouvoir sont légion au sein de
la recherche et ne savent pas
nécessairement l'intérêt général pouvez
vous nous indiquer sur quels critères
vous vous appuyez pour juger de la
crédibilité d'une étude scientifique les
financements sont il déterminant mes
critères sont-ils méthodologique la
réputation des scientifiques est elle
impliquée et une autre question avec
toute l'expérience que vous avez eue
lors de la crise sanitaire de lakovic 19
tous les patients que vous avez ausculté
ou avait pris un soin et avec toute
l'expérience que vous avez en ce qui
concerne les épidémies est ce que vous
avez pu constater une efficacité
provenant d'une autre molécule que la
chloroquine sur un stade en particulier
ou sur tous les stades de la maladie si
oui quelles molécules et sur quel stade
actuellement
donc moi vous savez y ait une manière de
d'analysé qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut un
métier qui est celle que l'on connaît
pour essayer de comparer les études
s'appelle les études de méta analyse
nous on a des gens chez nous on fait une
étude de méta analyse qui dissèque
vraiment les différentes études je vous
ai dit et donc on n'a rien on a mis on a
regardé avec l'hydro xi chloroquine
alors c'était fascinant parce que
c'était la première fois qu'on voyait ça
on voyait que les les réponses étaient
de deux côtés et de deux côtés d'une
manière tranchée ce qui n'est pas
compréhensible
voyez c'est à dire c'est bizarre alors
qu'il y avait il ya 4 et ferrando miyagi
à 4 rando lisation qui ont été proposées
dont trois étaient en faveur montré que
les roxy chloroquine était supérieur
les autres essais étaient des essais
comparatifs entre la population et les
seuls des fc les seules études qui
montrait un effet qui n'étaient pas
jusqu'à l'étude au coverage attend
qu'elle soit il faut attendre que les
choses soient publiés entre et
déclarations publiques
je reviendrai là dessus et puis la
réalité
un peu de différence le seul qui était
de l'autre côté était liée soit ou fait
c'étaient des étuis qui était uniquement
des études informatiques parfaite par
les gens qui avaient observé les malades
mais les saisies de données
hospitalières du pdci d'accord ou
l'équivalent donc du big data dont celle
du nom de cette 1e et tout avait les
conflits d'intérêts tout était associé à
guilers donc il y avait un cluster in
vous peut le regarder a le premier
auteur et mathieu millions sairlines et
donc ça montre que on peut analyser
parfaitement les données et on peut ne
pas se laisser trop mais je vais vous
donner un exemple qui qui peut être vous
éclairera et j'ai eu une longue
discussion avec les gens d'une lente est
à ce propos une fois qu'ils sont sortis
cette étude la même semaine dans le land
il y avait trois articles étaient rivés
notre article sur 3700 patients sur
lequel nous n'avions aucun mort avec lés
qui pouvait être imputables à hydroxy
croquer sur 3700 personnes
d'accord c'est l'étude qui est
maintenant line tu avais le public il y
avait en même temps cette étude
fantasque de des pieds nickelés
américain donc tout le monde pouvait
voir quelle était pas vrai il y avait
une troisième étude que je connais pas
ce que c'est moi qui en ai fait la
review qui rapportait l'expérience de
tous l'association internationale des
rhumatologues acquises ont demandé quand
vous avez une polyarthrite rhumatoïde et
que vous donnez les roxy coquine parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on les traite ou
vous donner un sulfamide il y avait neuf
cent trente mille personnes dans un
groupe les 350 millions dans l'autre
groupe
il n'y a aucune différence sur les
accidents cardiaques il y en a pas c'est
pas vrai et ils ont rejeté les deux qui
disait qu'il n'y ait pas d'accident et
ils ont publié l'histoire pieds nickelés
donc bon jeu pas très paranoïaque 1 mais
globalement la c'est une situation
commence à se poser des questions qui
dépassent sacré voyez c'est à dire les
trois dans la même semaine je vous le
jure que j'avais pire bien un que je
voulais l'autre que j'ai envoyés ont été
rejetées le mien sans révision extérieur
l'autre après que je vais retrouver
prochainement et d'autre et suggérer la
publication et ils ont gardé le
troisième et qu'ils ont dû rétracter
tellement ils étaient comics et comme
personne ne pourrait croire cette bêtise
ils ont dû le rétracter g donc parce
qu'ils ont reçu 20 mètres dont une des
nôtres qui avait accepté avant qu'ils
sont être acteur direct c'est vraiment
du problème et puis il ya une pétition
qui est parti du type qui est plus connu
au monde dans les maladies tropicales
qui s'appelle nick white avec toute
l'équipe d'oxford qui tenez vous pouvez
pas publier chose pareille quand même
donc quand même peut-être que c'est par
hasard par une incompétence terrible
mais le lancer est avaient le choix
entre trois ils auraient pu mettre un
éditorial
c'est ce que je leur ai dit a posteriori
j'ai fait un article là dessus quand on
est comme ça où on lance pas tout alors
qu'on a les trois articles soit on en
publie deux soit on dit on à un
éditorial ou un comments qui dit le
contraire accor qui dit écoutez c'est
balance et c'est quand même bizarre qui
est 10 % de mortalité personne ne les ai
jamais vus voyez donc de là à dire ça
choix délibéré je n'en sais rien
j'espère que non que c'est juste de la
coke réflexe d'un composteur au sommet
mais il ya quand même franchement donc
il y a eu un problème avec la drogue
thick rocky le on verra bien laisser
recovery mais c'est assez je m'excuse de
vous dire ça mais quand la décision a
été prise en france de supprimer la
chloroquine ya le ministre de la santé
de la guinée qui a dit aux français ce
que vous n'êtes pas un peu bizarre vous
parce que l'on connaît bien et claudine
on comprend même pas ce que vous dites
on l'utilisé beaucoup plus que vous et
là quand les anglais ont publié leur
méthodologie pour recovery
il ya le groupe des médecins internistes
indien qui a dit écoutez oxford ils ont
un problème parce qu'ils savent pas
utiliser l'hydroxyde rocklyn il utilise
à quatre fois la dose et c'est la dose
toxique de 24 de 2,4 grammes par jour
plus ensuite des doses qui était à fra
thérapeutique donc si vous voulez c'est
pareil à un autre truc dans recovery qui
est qui est très très très très
inquiétant c'est que les corticoïdes
font partie de dunes des soins courants
réanimation pour les pneumonies sévères
et donc de mettre les corticoïdes non
pas dans la décision médicale malades
par malade ce qui se fait si vous
regardez dans les séries qui sont
publiées partout dans le monde
il ya entre 10 et 30% des gens qui
reçoivent des corticoïdes dans les
réanimations en fonction du tableau
clinique de dire non ça en fait de
l'expérimentation
là dessus ça revient sur un des
problèmes qu'il ya eu dans ce pays c'est
que les malades ont été transformés en
objets des essais thérapeutiques et
c'était pas ce qui te laisse faire merci
julien pour osi oui merci madame la
présidente vous parliez tout à l'heure
de données brutes et je pense que il
faut quand même pas pouvoir les
interpréter je reviens sur le compare à
dire que vous avez fait entre les taux
de mortalité parisiens et marseillais
tout d'abord vous interroger sur
l'origine de vos chiffres puisqu'il n'ya
pas de publications de la connaissance
de deux chiffres par ville pour paris on
peut le comprendre mais pour marseille
on comprend moins vu qu'il s'agit des
bouches du rhône
d'autre part évidemment sachant qu'on a
un taux de mortalité forte heureusement
que la plupart du temps les gens s'en
sortent bien
fort heureusement malgré le nombre
tragique de mort évidemment plus on
teste et plus le taux de mortalité
baisse mécaniquement
et puis il est vrai que les populations
ne sont pas les mêmes entre paris et
marseille il est vrai aussi que les
bouches du rhône et la région paca a été
moins touchée que la région parisienne
dont je voudrais voir votre analyse là
dessus deuxième point je reviens quand
même rapidement sur votre départ du du
conseil scientifique parce que je
voulais aborder le sujet de de
l'humilité de la modestie qu'on devrait
tous avoir vis-à-vis de cette maladie et
de l'humain que nous sommes tous dans ce
conseil il y avait aussi une volonté
éthique et je pense qu'il aurait été au
contraire intéressant d'avoir des
données d'un expert tel que vous êtes
pour orienter les décisions sur la
partie humaine et éthiques
et c'est je trouve dommage c'est plus
une constatation qu'une question enfin
dernière chose je reviens un petit peu
sur ce que disait mon collègue de la
garde par rapport à la méthodologie que
vous avez employé
vous avez beaucoup pas de la
méthodologie de devaux consoeurs et
confrères mais c'est vrai que on a un
peu l'impression d'abord que vous avez
associés donc azithromycine est aussi
que l'euro qui je peux comprendre le
présent le conseil de leur sachant qu'on
est sûr de médicaments qui augmente le
cul tu es donc avec des risques
cardiaques majeurs et je pense qu'il
faut faire attention à ne pas prescrire
sous le coup de l'émotion pour ne pas
vous paraphraser mais ce que je voudrais
comprendre c est ce que vous ne pensez
pas que vous avez finalement été le
meilleur ennemi
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine avec ses ces
études qui avaient des billets
probablement au niveau du protocole et
qui a entraîné manifestement un ressenti
péjoratif dès le départ merci si vous
voulez le chemin pour pour pour répondre
à votre dernière question vous savez je
pense que ce m'excuse de vous dire ça
c'est en france on a l'habitude de se
regarder le nombril encore plus dans
cette ville que partout ailleurs
vous savez il ya des enquêtes de ça
aussi il y a probablement 50% des
médecins dans le monde qui utilisent
l'hydroxyde rocklyn et a dit robbie
keane pour traiter le coville je sais
pas si vous voyez le nombre que ça fait
dans le monde d'accord et en france
aussi
donc vous pensez que message apparemment
entendu il ya des gens qui l'ont pas
entendu beaucoup de gens qui l'ont
entendu et qu'il a entendu et qui en
payent le droit de le faire
parmi ceux qui l'ont entendu donc je
pense qu'il ya deux problèmes qui
dépassent
moi je veux bien que le lait les anglais
disent qu'ils mettent en jeu qu'il faut
tuer le porteur de la nouvelle je suis
d'accord dont je suis d'accord pour
faire le héros donc bouc émissaire si
vous voulez mais la vraie question n'est
pas celle là est encore une fois moi je
j'ai commencé en disant simplement c'est
les chinois viennent de faire une en
train de finir leur épidémies sont en
train de dire comment ils ont géré leur
épidémies et donc on va commencer parce
que c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
quand on est humble effectivement est
quand même plus on est sachant plus on
est humble on va commencer par regarder
ce qu'ils ont eue l'épidémie tout ce
qu'ils ont fait qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils avaient des scanners low dose
en particulier au genre est
symptomatique qu'ils entreraient des
lésions
c'est eux qui ont trouvé les premières
fibrose ils ont fait des greffes de
poumons sur les fibroses 1 donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses côté publié
en chine ses les premiers alors virus et
les premiers à voir tester des
médicaments sur ce virus les deux
premiers c'était la chloroquine mti dire
c'est les premiers alors traiter les
malades
cette communication officielle là dessus
ils ont fait des recommandations qui en
rien à voir avec les autres avec les
nôtres et je suis d'accord avec verizon
dit écoutez traiter vos malades mais
leur donnait pas plus de trois
antiviraux à la fois parce qu'après
trois ans c'est parce que ça fait et
dedans il y avait tout ce qui
potentiellement avait une activité
antivirale parce que leur désir c'était
de dire aux gens
soignez soigner soigner je suis d'accord
avec ça donc c'est pas et comme étant et
je passais deux fois la télévision 1,4
milliard de doses eater ok sinon à 100
quand même beaucoup plus souvent
appliquée et stratégies thérapeutiques
avec lequel je suis d'accord que les
pays il faut pour répondre ensuite avec
400 sur marseille vous savez il faut
arrêter de se regarder le nombril et
arrêter toute cette histoire c'est parce
que les gens ici sont crus ils pas
qu'ici en europe de l'ouest les gens
sont crus plus malins ils ont des
mauvaises habitudes
c'est là qu'on est mort le plus c'est
l'angleterre la france la belgique et
l'espagne l'italie la rattraper parce
qu'elle a commencé à faire du test
massif à donner leurs tripes de routine
dès qu'ils ont compris comment ça se
passe et donc il y avait un départ
extraordinaire actuellement une
mortalité plus basse et peut-être que
l'amérique et rattrapera et vous
regardez les quinze premiers pays ces 15
pays riches du groupe europe etats unis
qui sont les pays qui sont les plus
touchés qui ont le plus de points
d'accord c'est une vraie question
donc c est ce qu on sait encore traiter
les maladies infectieuse aiguë sans que
ça devienne ou un marché où un conflit
politique ou que ça rentre dans la
guerre civile américaine
vous savez bien que c'est pas moi qui
fais que ça vous fout tu es un truc
mondiale s'ajoutait un truc génial parce
que tron s'est emparé de ça au milieu
d'une guerre civile américaine entre les
pro et les anti trump quoi j'ai rien à
voir donc le leu leu il faut pas trop
tuer le messager encore une fois moi je
venais rapporté que des choses très
simples vous devriez plutôt poser la
question comment se fait-il que les
chinois ayant dit écoutez nous la
première molécule que nous avons testé
la première sur lequel nous ayons des
résultats c'est la chloroquine comment
se fait-il qu'en france on n'est jamais
oublier ça dans un bras sauf quand il
était trop tard pour le faire
ça c'est une vraie question alors que
moi c'est pas moi le premier à rapporter
la claudine j'ai rapporté ce que les
chinois je dirais que c'est la première
porte ouverte il faut probablement
arrêté par les chinois comme des
imbéciles
parce que moi j'ai vu comment il
travaillait et puis j'ai pas vu
laboratoires en france qui a ressemblé à
ce que j'ai vu une chine et donc
je crois qu'ils sont bien merci
je dois pas laisser penser que les
médecins donc pas soigner en france et
que les chercheurs n'ont pas cherché il
ne continue pas de chercher donc on va
continuer évidemment avec les questions
de mes collègues mais je voulais juste
mettre ce bémol donc monsieur mechita
pour pour répondre à celui de vos
questions c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
encore une fois il faut regarder le la
mortalité brut par million d'habitants
ce qui est un point donc ça c'était un
phénomène qui est relativement
indépendant des tests qui dépend de
l'épidémiologie mais j'ai dit quelque
chose que je suis en profite pour vous
répéter en regardant en revanche la
structure de la mortalité est témoin de
la qualité des soins
c'est à dire que si vous avez dans un
même échantillon de 100 personnes
vous avez 9% ou 8 % de morts de moins de
65 ans ou s'il avait le double ça
signifie qui s'est passé quelque chose
dans la qualité de la prise en charge et
du soin et ça c'est indépendant de la
fréquence c'est indépendant des tests
sommes d'accord et on a assez donné
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
professeur deux questions la première
comment expliquer que certaines régions
en france aient pu être plus touchés que
d'autres
je vous dise en qualité de président du
groupe agir ensemble mais également en
qualité de député mulhouse qui étaient
particulièrement touchés vous déclariez
récemment que certaines personnes
pouvaient avoir une immunité peut être
naturel ce que vous pourriez nous en
dire plus et le professeur delfraissy
disait ici la semaine dernière que l'on
pouvait aussi avoir des super
contaminateur c'est à dire des personnes
qui avaient une charge virale très forte
et dont le cas échéant les gouttelettes
de pouvait rester en aérosols dans l'air
et contaminer un nombre beaucoup plus
important de personnes est ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur ce premier
point je veux vous dit
le peu que je sais et si vous voulez les
gens qui vous expliquent qu'ils ont
compris quelque chose s'en vont au delà
de ce qui est la connaissance générale
des maladies d'écosystèmes le les
maladies infectieuses d'écosystèmes
personnel et d'écosystèmes général on
comprend pas du tout moi je m'intéresse
depuis les années j'ai même fait des
numéros spéciaux dans la littérature là
dessus sur le phénomène saisonnier
je comprends absolument pas par exemple
éclipsé la caisse maladie très grave
c'est plus fréquent en septembre octobre
pourquoi je sais toujours pas pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que nous la grippe c'est
que intrus ends à ça vient je crois de
handfield a dit fredo l'affluence du
froid ça a été écrit je crois que c'est
fracasserait décrit ça parce que ça
survenait pendant l'hiver d'accord et
donc pour nous la grippe a toujours été
une infection divers mais on pensait ça
jusqu'à encore relativement peu de temps
parce qu'on a étudié ça dans les pays
tempérés dans les pays est en paix il ya
un hiver mais au fait je le travaille
beaucoup en afrique et à des grilles
pour l'année et en a plus la saison de
pluie mais personne ne peut expliquer sa
danse aérien toute l'année d'accord et
il ya des choses des choses extrêmement
étrange et on a un travail beaucoup avec
les migrants qui vont en arabie saoudite
ouais j'ai même eu un contrôle karabi
saoudite pour essayer de comprendre les
échanges de microbes qui sont pas ce que
j'ai vu comment ça se passe le pairage
de la mecque maloyas une densité humaine
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé à mulhouse
c'est un truc 3 millions qui tournent
ensemble c'est un truc qui est
impressionnant eh bien on conteste tout
légende demain on a fait une grosse
étude sur 2000 personnes avec le port
d'où venaient les microbes et nous on
teste depuis dix ans et philippe gautry
kleiza chez moi qui qui teste tous les
gens qui partent et tous les gens qui
reviennent donc on sont volontaires on
leur fait un prélèvement écouvillon
pharyngés ils se font même un auto
prélevant des clients et à l'avant après
on regarde ce n'est qu'aux européennes
regardent ce qui se passe et on a des
gens qui reviennent avec la grippe parce
qu'il rencontre par le
la fête de l'aïd a été ces dernières
années plutôt l'été et donc ils
reviennent ils rencontrent là bas des
gens qui sont dans une période
saisonnière où il ya de la grippe
ils reviennent avec la grippe il n'y a
pas de cas secondaires even dans l'été
la grippe il n'y a pas de cas
secondaires d'accord parce que les
conditions écologiques ne sont pas
favorables au fait que les cas
secondaires donc on a une théorie pour
essayer d'expliquer mais c'est
extrêmement complexe donc c'est pour ça
que vous expliquer ce que va être la
répartition d'une épidémie tout ce qu'on
sait c'est que les épidémies dans
histoire l'humanité ça toujours
commencer de seat arrêter à un moment
donc c'est c'est même les pires qu'on
connaît a l'impression que maintenant
citer tout le temps mais ce n'est pas
tout le temps on avait des vagues
épidémiques avariée vale vale épidémie
qu'on sait pas pourquoi après tout le
monde peut avoir une explication en
disant c'est le niveau de l'immunité
général c'est mérité on n'en sait rien
une vraie question est donc ça explique
pourquoi
d'abord il ya des phénomènes le le sarc
par exemple vous donner un exemple parce
que c'est quand même pas un virus qui
est très loin
toutes les études qui avaient été faites
sur le sable ça avait été fait
énormément d'études ont été faites à
hong kong sur deux hôtels dans lequel
est truqué laon c'est là qu'on a dit
yahya super contaminateur c'est un type
qui avait prêté sa cave au milieu du
couloir et puis tous les gens qui
étaient à taper ça donc il ya eu il a
contaminé on a estimé 100 personnes
alors que le taux de ré le ratio de
contamination au moyen de deux ou trois
donc c'est de là qu'est née l'idée du
sper contaminateur et donc on sait
toujours pas ce qui s'est passé
sauf que les vomissements sont beaucoup
plus contaminant que les autres mais que
mécanique parce que le volume de
beaucoup plus grand et il a beaucoup
plus mais dix ans après le sar ça a été
rapportée un très bon journal l'étude de
la distribution de sa part des
techniques sérologique spécifique du
sart ce et on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
ait des gens qui avaient été affectés
jusqu'à 100 mètres de l'hôtel sans qu'on
l'ait jamais vu et sans qu'on comprenne
comment c'est possible
d'accord donc s'ils voulaient notre
degré c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles moi j'étais un tel partisans
d'observer tester observé tester observé
on n'a pas été déçu retrouvez tout ce
qu'on voulait plein de choses parce que
si vous voulez quand vous êtes face à
une maladie inconnue toute opinion est
fausse et donc il faut commencer par
observer collecter les données et même
une fois qu'on a collecté le maximum de
données
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
mieux parce que comme dit et chercheurs
continuent à chercher et donc il faut le
laisser du travail pour ceux qui
viendront après mais je peux vous dire
que pour l'épidémiologie des maladies
infectieuses du travail va rester c'est
il ya une immense partie de ça je vais
vous dire vous savez d'où ça vient vous
avez l'idée du d'où ça vient le il faut
savez les mains pour les affections
respiratoires s'est coincé mais je peux
vous dire il ya à peu près 20 ans je
découvre ça j'ai review et pour le 27 un
papier de gens qui avaient fait une
étude ans au pakistan en faisant par
bloc au pakistan des gens à qui donner
des ça on a refait la même étude au
sénégal un trou même chose des blogs de
gens qui donnait des savon pour se laver
tous les jours et puis ils vérifiaient
que les gens se laver les mains tous les
jours et prenez un bain une fois par
cela seul avait une fois par semaine et
il cherchait pour ça quelque chose qui
était très logique qu'ils étaient et
gastro entérite parce qu'on sait que les
gastro entérites
vous connaissez beaucoup de maladies
qu'on l'appelle manu portet qui sont
paix qu'on appelle le péril fécal et
donc c'était ça qu'on cherchait et comme
contrôle ils ont pris les pneus moyens
et ils ont une énorme surprise qu'avait
les pneumonies diminuer autant que les
gastro entérites et c'est la première
fois qu'on a vu qu'on d'éviter les
pneumonies dans sa langue et que c'était
avec la vectorisation massive des
infections respiratoires
c'est les mains etc d'une découverte par
hasard et donc avec nos méthodologistes
on n'aurait pas pu le voir parce que
c'était pas des objectifs primaires de
voir la diminution des pneumonies et la
plupart des grandes découvertes y font
par hasard en réalité c'est pas des
choses qu'on a prévu une sinon on les
aurait testé avant merci
alors je voudrais pas vous presser on a
encore beaucoup de questions monsieur
professeurs alors martine vos nerfs je
dis au président mars par jean
il me restait merci question donc je
sais mais j'ai volontairement restera ma
première question pour pouvoir poser
la seconde vous aviez
10 au début de l'épidémie que le
confinement était une technique
moyenâgeuse et qu'il fallait tester
isolé soigner bon on nous a expliqué qu'
il n'y avait pas d'autre choix possible
compte tenu de l'évolution au stade où
nous étions et du manque de moyens
aujourd'hui considérez vous que la
france est prête à éviter un recond
finement alors qu'on constate dans
d'autres régions du monde qu'on est en
train de re confiné lorsqu'on est face à
une seconde vague et dernière question
quel conseil donneriez vous aux français
qui nous regardent aujourd'hui pour
justement se protéger de la propagation
de ce virus
longtemps vous fassiez une démonstration
ses défauts chez nous dans les hachures
je pense qu'il ya eu la plus grande
concentration de malades de france pour
le monde des plus grandes concentrations
du monde 5000 personnes infectées qui
sont passés là dedans quand même en deux
ans et demi le taux d'infection du
personnel est plutôt inférieur à celui
de la ville entière donc le personnel
n'a pas été affecté il ya eu un seul
médecin non un médecin qui ont été
affectés dans tous les chu donc avec des
moyens qui sont bien entendu toutes les
précautions direct de contacts etc
mais le masque est indispensable pour
les soignants parce qu'on a des rapports
avec les malades qui sont très proximo
on est à 20 30 cm et là les masques sont
essentiels et sinon on se passe les
mains à l'alcool cent fois par jour
honda distributeurs d'alcool partout et
moi dre j'avais passé jugé c'est une des
autres choses pardon et que j'ai montré
au président à chaque fois qu'on passe
devant une décrue est d'accord on se met
de la colle dessus serait donc je n'ai
pas attrapé j'ai pas pris de prophylaxie
par hydroxy cantine donc je n'ai pas
attrapé
donc c'est le moyen le plus efficace
je vous dis après le fait que je sois
marseillais fait que j'ai une opinion
sur les épidémies bien entendu c'est une
ville qui a été soumise toutes les
épidémies que vous pouvez imaginer cinq
ou six peste et au choléra et la
quarantaine des bateaux vous voyez
comment ça marche
on a deux exemples majeur voiliers de
quarantaine des bateaux la fin tout le
monde est affecté pas tout le monde
enfin beaucoup le lazaret celle inverse
on disait que les gens c'est la même
chose que le salon on isole que les gens
qui sont affectés d'accord et comme ça
ils propagent pas la maladie tant qu'ils
sont infectieux et donc nous dans les h
et une des parties difficiles et
importantes et pour lequel d'ailleurs on
n était présidée par nos institutions
je veux dire très solennellement que il
ya des points de désaccord sur la
gestion générale que le truc mais un on
a été aidé jamais personne nous empêcher
de travailler
nous avons été aidés par nos tutelles
par la rs et kid on est en contact
permanent avec la dgs donc l'expérience
qu'il était je crois nécessaire que nous
montrions dans les chu est une
expérience qui a été menée entièrement
sans que nous n'ayons ni la moindre
barre hier
donc peu importe les gens qui râlent
d'étudiants maya m'en fous je viens
battait vision eux mais globalement donc
nous avons pu mener ce que je pensais
être dans deux voire entièrement donc je
n'ai pas de neuner pas eu des obstacles
je n'ai pas eu d'ennuis on va pas
embêter un peu conseil de l'ordre est
venu me dire que je ne vais pas parler
puis j'ai ramené à la constitution la
france du pays quand même parce que
j'avais que je connais très bien un des
meilleurs constitutionnaliste de ce pays
ça fait partie de la constitution la
liberté d'expression des enseignants
donc je peux pas m'empêcher de parler de
squash cours donc je dois pas me le
faire donc pas convoqués pour tâche
n'est pas loin de faire j'aurais dit
qu'ils les gardent leurs opinions pour
qu'ils fassent un peu ce qu'ils
voulaient mais qui permettent
il y avait déjà essayé de faire samedi 2
mai que de mes collègues et ce qu'ils
avaient perdu devant le conseil d'état
donc le à l'avenir je crois qu'il faut
réfléchir mais pour pouvoir le faire il
faut avoir des tests pour pouvoir faire
les tests il faut avoir des endroits et
nous ce que nous faisions aléas chut on
avait déterminé sur la pcr un pcr ne
prédit pas très précisément en
affectivité mais nous on a des moyens
culture considérable donc on a isolé
2000 souche je ne sais pas si quelqu'un
autres laboratoires dans le monde qu'à
isoler 2000 souches sur la séquence et
500 pour l'instant mais et ça faisait
deux fois plus que le reste de la france
donc on n'est peut-être pas un centre
national de référence ont fait vraiment
fait beaucoup
on sait que à partir d'un certain
c'était un certain seuil il reste des
acides nucléiques du virus mais le virus
est mort il est plus cultivables donc
ils sont plus contagieux donc tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours à
l'instar de 8 heures un stage à 10h30
cette affaire à 8h en vrd qui avait là
et à 10h30 on faisait sortir tout ce qui
n'était plus contagieux pour le mettre
dans d'autres services de l'assistance
publique et ça veut dire que tous les
jours on en faisait sortir 25 % d'accord
et donc c'est comme ça qu'on gère ils
sont plus contagieuses le fait sortir
d'accord ils sont contagieux dans qui
sont contagieux on les garde
et généralement en moyenne au bout de
trois quatre jours il est plus
contagieux merci alors martin wagner
merci madame la présidente professeur
alors vous nous avez dit que vous étiez
en contact régulièrement avec les plus
hautes instances de ce pays
mais avez-vous eu l'impression d'être
entendus ou d'être compris pourquoi état
d'urgence
le 23 mars suite à cet état d'urgence
deux décrets 25 et 26 mars qui ne
réserve l'hydroxyde chloroquine cas des
stades tardifs hospitalier avec toute
une grade graduation d'état cliniques
graves
or c'est pas du tout votre protocole
puisque d'equihen patients testés
positifs
vous vous mettez en place la bithérapie
ou tel que vous allez nous leur ai
expliqué mais peut-être qu'un autre
messager était plus entendu parce que
dès la réunion du 5 mars de près conseil
scientifique
les laboratoires sont présents et le
chef de service de bichat yazdan
yazdanpanah qui n'a que le mot rêve d y
virent à la bouche est présent également
alors peut-être était-il un message et
qu'ils étaient plus écouté que vous
qu'en pensez vous pardon je vais vous
demander de finir toutes vos questions
parce que là on a on a encore beaucoup
de demandes après donc c'est pas
possible où on avait dit au départ c'est
parce que je en route ça c'est ça a
bougé mais dans vos deux minutes voilà
d'accord c'est pour faciliter les
réponses du professeur autre question
concernant votre étude la dernière
non vous avez publié l'abstract avez
vous une idée de quand elle va sortir
parce que peut-être que ça nous
éclairerait définitivement sur le
protocole à suivre
et peut-être ray rhdp remettre en france
si vous étiez entendu aux médecins de
première ligne au médecin traitant
cette possibilité d'utiliser ou pas
cette molécule selon les résultats que
dont vous n'allez nous parler et donc
cette liberté de prescription en france
qui quelque part a été interdite et dans
la région où je suis élue comme comme
monsieur brecht
la problématique était que des patients
ont sursaturé les établissements et je
pense qu'on aurait pu éviter cette en
effet cette ce transfert en
hospitalisation
là encore si les médecins de première ni
avait eu le droit de dépister d'isoler
de confiner peut-être mais surtout de
traiter ce qui a manqué complètement
dans la stratégie il me semble merci
professeur alors de deux choses le
l'arrêté du 1er arrêté du ministre était
plus subtil que ça pour répondre autre
qui m'était notamment donc c'était
s'était notamment aux formes les plus
graves
c'était notamment donc ce qui fait que
je les appelais et il m'a dit 'il m'a
marqué notamment donc ça veut dire que
notamment donc c'est une subtilité qui
permettait ce qu'ils lisaient pas qu'ils
aient pas l'exégèse du test de du texte
de dire que les formes qui n'était pas
grave ne pouvait pas être testés donc je
continue à les traiter en accord avec
l'arrêté le la deuxième chose je suis
d'accord je pense que l'environnement
d'abord moi quand j'ai commencé à
discuter que militaire m'a tout de suite
dit celui qui va gérer les essais ce qui
va faire un truc cis la télé but le
début des débuts et dieu le début il m'a
parlé que des hommes décidés dès le
début avant même que la sensibilité d'un
décès liés au virus soit soit soient
testés donc moi je dis sur le sahara
s'il ya un parti mais il ya un
antibiotique pavage de table s'appelle
la targo side qui marche bien
qui avaient été testées pour kelly un
brevet dont il ya des solutions
alternatives et pas que ça donc ça c'est
un point je suis très sceptique sur la
qualité de l'environnement pour les
médicaments et pour les choix
thérapeutiques du ministre je pense que
son environnement n'est qu'au comme
comme je voulais dit l'ancien directeur
de l'année c'est mais l'ancien président
de la chasse ont exprimé publiquement
leur désaccord avec leurs successeurs
et je suis d'accord avec les
prédécesseurs donc je pense que et je
crois que c'est très important si je
peux l'exprimer comme ça à ma manière
vous me pardonnerez vous savez ces
ministres effectivement des problèmes
c'est qui qui est il reste pas très
longtemps mais théoriquement ils ont une
garde prétorienne si vous voulez de
directeur de très très grande qualité
si les directeurs qui ont autant sont
pas très grandes qualités sont pas ne
font pas mûres entre le le flux
d'informations alarmantes permanent
auquel est soumis le mini ce ci a pas de
mur c'est la personne qui traite les
données d'une manière efficace et
sérieuse alors le ministre est exposé
d'une manière qui est insupportable
je pense ça je pense que donc il faudra
c'est une des choses demandées à
l'avenir je considère être extrêmement
attentif à la qualité des gens qui sont
mis en place pour constituer la première
ce que j'appelle la garde prétorienne se
voulait la première sécurité des
ministres pour assurer leur qualité de
façon à ce que le ministre ne soit pas
submergés d'informations inquiétantes
qui ne se révèlent jamais vrai parce que
tout ça n'a jamais été publié après moi
je peux vous dire que les informations
qui ont circulé
le nombre de morts prétendu vous le
savez je crois vous avez fait un truc on
disait il ya eu tant de morts avec
l'hydro xi coquine et temps d'arrêt
cardiaque et après il restait rien du
tout quand ils étaient analysées c'était
pas vrai mais c'était transmis
directement et sans décoffrage au
ministre la santé qui étaient affolés
par ce flux d'information affolé faut
faire attention que la garde prétorienne
ebener et de la connaissance
parce que sinon on affole les gens en
place et après ils prennent des
décisions liées au niveau d'information
qu'ils ont et quand même si je crois que
le ministre écoutent ce que je dis après
ce n'est pas la seule information qu'il
est là c'est pas moi qui suis en
permanence al conseillers et à lui
donner des conseils donc si les conseils
de proximité sont faits par des gens qui
n'ont pas les nerfs ou qui n'ont pas la
compétence c'est un véritable problème
monsieur le professeur vous portez un
constat sévère et est grave puisque vous
décrivez un peu un ministre sous
influence avec des directeurs quelques
ailes directeur vous ciblez aujourd'hui
sur cette faiblesse clairement pour les
médicaments c'est le directeur l'année
c'est mai puis le président de la haute
autorité de santé avait clairement c'est
eux qui ont pris ces décisions c'est
vrai que le conseiller du de maladies
infectieuses et là aussi à des conflits
d'intérêts que seulement sérieux dans la
haute autorité de santé que vous pouvez
regarder sur internet aussi c'est pas
compliqué tout ça donc il y a là des
réflexions à avoir encore une fois de
fond sur je ne dis pas que le ministre
est sous influence je lui il a mis ce ne
peut pas ne pas être sous influence et
un cabinet qui n'a pas choisi la des
directeurs qui n'a pas choisi il arrive
au milieu d'une crise donc si le les
gens qui représentent la force
institutionnel n'ont pas la capacité de
le protéger et au contraire lui font
croire que pour le protéger il faut
qu'ils interdisent des choses qui vont
tuer les gens bien entendu on a eu des
situations qui finissent par être
paradoxal où l'on finit par être seul au
monde quand même à penser ça donc à
prendre des mesures aussi radicales
donc je pense que ça doit amener
sûrement une réflexion je pense que vous
devriez vous la connaissez bien moi je
dis on devrait voir mais attendez il
faut organiser quelques pourquoi est ce
que les prédécesseurs ont un point de
vue radicalement différents de ceux qui
leur ont juste succéder pourquoi ils
expriment en public et puis ce n'est pas
robuste et une robustesse que tout le
monde connaît merci monsieur sont de
forget merci madame la présidente
je suis professeur yao déjà je souhaite
vous dire tout toute mon admiration et l
est et l'admiration de beaucoup de
français pour votre pouvoir transparence
pour votre travail acharné vous attaquer
un faiseur et c'est vrai un sachant est
un faiseur et et c'est assez rare en
france aujourd'hui pour être pour être
souligné la maire préliminaire je
souhaitais juste savoir parce que vous
venez de quand même porter des
accusations sur l'année scène sur la
chaise est-ce que vous parlez de la
haute autorité de santé ou du haut
conseil de la santé publique
je continue laquelle à la question si je
comprends bien le président je souhaite
aussi aller dans votre champ sur les
dangers sur les dangers de consolidation
des fabricants de temps dans la
pharmacie que dans le les matériaux in
vitro puisque vous avez parlé des
ruptures très actif d'extraction de
qiagen
mais on a fait leur on a eu le même
problème de blocage avec thermo fisher
est en fait en creusant on se rend
compte que quel gène est un mot fischer
on sent la même société avec même
propriétaire si donc là c'est vrai dans
la pharma comme c'est vrai dans le reste
des dispositifs médicaux
moi je sais que ce que ce qui me pose
souci vous avez parlé des lazarets et
finalement on en fait le confinement on
a fait des lazarets improvisé alors que
personne ne revenais de terre sainte et
que personne n'était lépreux et
finalement vous nous parlez de séquelles
aujourd'hui donc et donc c'est à dire
qu'on est dit aux gens restez chez vous
et il semble que même chez les gens qui
survivent à rds sévère sinon
respiratoires sévères et séquelles
neurologiques chantant et pulmonaires
donc moi je souhaiterais que avoir votre
avis sur cette attitude finalement de
confiner à la hâte et puis d'avoir
peut-être négligé des effets à long
terme de la part de la pathologie sur 7
sur cette base est peut-être peut-être
pourquoi moi je comprends votre logique
de tester massivement avec votre
traitement à simple et peu coûteux c'est
à dire de diminuer aussi le portage
virale et donc la contagiosité
alors est-ce que l'internât tive idéal
utt donc de tester massivement et
d'accompagner cette démarche par ce
traitement simple et peu coûteux parce
que finalement il y avait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour notamment des pays pauvres
on passe d'un pays pauvres à voir avec
des signes cliniques
qui permettait de diagnostiquer la
maladie avec une grande sensibilité
d'une grande spécificité comme la noce
me élagueuse y ait à la fois des
traitements existants est simple et des
démarches finalement que tout a donc
tout à chacun aurait pu saisir et
pourquoi
pourquoi avoir manqué ce cela dans nos
pays développés merci encore une fois il
est possible que j'ai cru comprendre que
vous étiez d'origine coréenne jeu encore
et c'est pareil les recommandations
étaient donner quelque chose aux
patients dont les drogues cycloclean
donc c'est pas s'il n'y a pas que les
pays pauvres il ya les pays d'extrême
orient et l'europe est isolé dans ce
l'europe et les états unis sont isolés
dans cette stratégie qui a été une
stratégie de de ne pas traiter de ne pas
traiter même et donc la vraie question
que vous posez qui a été probablement la
raison pour laquelle enfin ou moins une
des raisons pour lesquelles a été levée
d'une manière absolument insensé la
toxicité de la dave brock si chloroquine
et l'azithromycine était que le bon sens
vous voulez que écouter on sais pas
jusqu'à quel point ça marche mais il
faut faire quelque chose pour les
malades
c'est ce qu'on a l'habitude de faire
tous quand même on n'a pas commencé à
faire de la médecine depuis un siècle
ça fait très longtemps que la médecine
et la médecine dont on donne on donne
quelque chose on soigne les malades et
d'ailleurs c'était une des choses si on
avait fait ça c'est pas seulement le
médicament c'est tout le soin qui est
autour très tôt on s'est rendu compte
qu'il fallait donner des anticoagulants
au début parce qu'ils avaient des
embolies nous le seul mort jeune que
l'on a eu 59 ans est mort parce qu'il a
fait une embolie pulmonaire et qu'on
l'avait pas antico régulier parce qu'on
savait pas à l'époque qu'il fallait anti
corps et de les gens donc donc au fur et
à mesure on apprenait bien entendu si on
fait des tests de saturation à l'oxygène
ça coûte 20 euros à savoir si on s'est
d'abord un testeur pour voir la
saturation en oxygène
si on fait la saturation à l'oxygène et
qu'on voit que les gens une saturation
qui est en tout cas 95 en dessous mais
on les prend l'hôpital en les oxygen où
les oxygen amusé on fait quelque chose
on n'attend pas qui sont en détresse
respiratoire parce que ils le sentiront
pas avant la détresse respiratoire
respiratoires donc il ya je crois
beaucoup
et même si vous voulez quand on renvoie
les gens qui sont positifs
qui savent qu'ils sont positifs d'abord
tout ceux qui sont négatifs sont
contents et puis ceux qui sont positifs
ont une manière de se comporter dans
leur propre famille qui n'est pas de
même nature que ceux qui ne sont pas
positifs et reviennent se faire tester
jusqu'au moment où ils sont négatifs et
donc il le s'isole dans leurs champs
mais sans fermer savent qu'ils
représentent un risque pour leurs
familles c'est pas la même nature que de
dire écoutez on sait pas qui c'est qui
est positif et il sut crise il pas
surtout quand vous pensez si les gens
pas de fièvre qui tousse pas ce qui ce
qui était le cas de la majorité des cas
quand même hein comment est ce qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont contagieux pour leurs
familles le savent pas donc si vous leur
dites vous êtes contagieux
vous pouvez penser qu'ils vont avoir un
comportement nature différente pour
protéger leurs familles et donc vous
allez diminuer le risque de contagion
même s'ils sont confinés donc je pense
encore fort mais je pense que tout le
monde le croit maintenant que la clé
c'est la détection et ça alors là en
revanche il ya des études si vous voulez
qu'ils montrent que le nombre de cas le
nombre de cas l'extension de la maladie
et la mortalité est lié au monde de
capter le maximum étant l'islande qui à
domota était le plus bas et qui a fait
le plus de tests par habitant donc ça on
sait que c'est une brique et ensuite la
clé 2 est ce que dans une situation
comme celle là il vaut mieux donner des
médicaments ou ne rien donner
la question se pose rapidement encore
une fois de savoir mais attendez vous
êtes en train de donner un poison mortel
à des gens quand encore une fois moi je
sais que il faut tuer le messager je
n'ai pas compris comment ça pouvait
déclencher un tel scénario de trucs ce
truc tu tout le monde quand on parlait
de deux des médicaments les plus
prescrits dans l'histoire de l'humanité
comme on comment on est arrivé à dire
que ces trucs-là avait toxicité aussi
incroyable alors que quand une fois les
auc cycloclean en 2019 elle était donnée
sans ordonnance et après on les trouvait
même plus on n'est même plus le droit de
la prescrire donc c'était ça pose des
problèmes et y compris parce que les
gens qui avaient d'autres maladies qui
avec des roxy coraux qui n'arrivait pas
à la voir dans les pharmacies comment on
est amené passer d'un côté à l'autre
sans que personne c'est vous qui voyez
vous posez sur mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi ce médicament qu'est ce
qui a changé dans ce médicament pour que
la france passe de on n'a même pas
besoin
lens a même avec une redondance on vous
le donne plus comme il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé quand même c'est pas moi
qui ai fait ça c'est pas le mais c'est
pas parce que j'ai dit peut-être je dis
bien hydroxyque au crible et je suis le
diable et certains le disent d'ailleurs
certains disent le contraire c'est ce
qui vaut d'être auditionné parfois jean
pierre door merci madame la présidente
oui ce professeur je retrouve le même
professeur raoul qu'en 2012 nous étions
croisés hier vous avez expliqué vos
critiques envers la haute autorité de
santé envers l'agencé nationale du
médicament
mais je sais que vous avez aussi
critiqué l' oms en la traitant de
pyromanes de la planète dans le domaine
des épidémies et bien entendu aussi le
haut conseil de santé publique donc
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi et plus
raisonnablement est-ce que vous avez
saisi le ministre lorsqu'il a déclaré
que adp stage large n'aurait aucun sens
au niveau médical et au niveau
scientifique
c'était sa phrase et enfin dernière
question que pensez-vous de l'essai de
la d'exams états zone en tant qu'anti
inflammatoires nouveaux dont on parle
depuis quelques jours ou quelques
semaines
merci je vais commencer par ça que je
vois que vous auriez beaucoup nous
incliner nouveau parce que nous avons
tous les deux
quel point les nouveaux bien sûr et même
débat d'ailleurs sur les usages c'est le
premier staff de médecine qu'elle j'ai
assisté à l'époque où il y avait un
hôpital de maladies infectieuses à
parité totale claude bernard j'étais
allé un simple d'y assister au staff et
le débat était déjà ce qu'il faut donner
pour ces cas là encore teaser n'ai pas
loupé à la cortisone donc c'est un débat
qui est très ancien qui est très
compliqué parce que franchement il ya
des indications spécifiques qui sont et
qui sont à choisir par le médecin
individuellement on peut pas faire des
tous les essais qui ont été faits avec
la dexaméthasone ou avec les autres
voitures
amen hélas si vous regardez bien le peu
qui est en train de sortir c'est qu'il
faut pas donner de cortisone à des gens
qui n'ont pas de couverture pour leurs
maladies infectieuses et donc quand ils
ont fait ça s'est aggravé
donc c'est à dire la première phase que
je vous décrivais qui est purement
virales ont été cortisone à grave parce
que vous baissez défensive
uniterre lahoud en est besoin là où les
défenses immunitaires deviennent folles
il est vraisemblable que ça rend un
service sap a été vraiment quantifier et
dans dans les sdr assez au kouhaku par
exemple les gens qui ont plus de 75 ans
leur donne pas de cortisone parce que ça
peut faire pire que d'être une tout ça
c'est de la médecine la cortisone c'est
quand même un vieux médicament qui a été
très utilisé le jeu je veux pas faire
encore une fois le l'exégèse des textes
ministériels parce que je crois que dans
la pression et avec les informations de
sources multiples dont je j'assume ma
part de responsabilité
c'est difficile d'avoir une ligne
continue
quand le vent souffle dans tous les sens
ces marins qui parle pour pour l'eau et
mais si vous voulez je pense il est
possible que nous ayons eue en europe de
l'ouest et réactions de jeu je pense que
nous sommes en ordre de l'ouest nous
sommes jeunes nous sommes devenus des
sociétés très fragile très réactive aux
crises y compris quand ces crises ne
sont pas réels et que si j'ai toujours
tenté d'être rassurant parce que je
crois que la peur est très mauvaise
conseillère
je pense qu'il faut aller dans le calme
sans peur et que donc de soulever la
peur ou de dramatiser donc fois que j'ai
parlé des choses j'ai tenté d'en de
prendre l'hypothèse la plus basse parce
que je pense que c'est mieux
je pense que c'est quitte à assumer gens
me disent écoutez c'est plus grave que
ce que vous disiez je l'assumé
entièrement mais si vous regardez le
moment où effectivement le le feu a été
mis à la plana la planète c'est au
moment de l'épidémie de e année puis de
iba et puis un peu plus en chine
en tout ça fait à peu près 6000 morts
tout ça à la fin de l'année en chine si
quelqu'un est d'avoir la différence avec
ces éléments et fort on verra pas la
différence
donc il ya eu une sur réaction de la
chine parce que la chine avait été
accusé pendant longtemps à l'om est
d'avoir caché le sarce et donc parce que
la chine donc la chine a réagi ça en
construisant des effectivement des
hôpitaux centres de recherche absolument
hallucinant extraordinaire et là mon
sens elle a eu
communication excessive du fait de sept
premiers épisodes de sas pour laquelle
était accusé de dissimuler les faits si
vous voulez en lançant un une alerte qui
tout bien analysé a posteriori est
totalement disproportionnée par rapport
à la populace l'ubaye c'est la
population de la france est le nom de
mort en chine c'est le nombre de morts
dans l'île de france
c'est ça la réalité
donc si vous voulez la halle alerte
initiale est une alerte qui est
entièrement disproportionnée vous croyez
aux chiffres chinois
moi si vous voulez je que je vois pas de
raison de ne pas croire aux chiffres
chinois je vois pas si vous voulez
pourquoi les chinois mentir et plus dans
quelque chose dont au contraire ils ont
dit que c'était ils ont plutôt eu
tendance mon point de vue a amplifié le
phénomène pour dire regardez comme on
est sérieux regarder quand on fit
d'ailleurs tout le monde a tourné toute
la chine d'ailleurs jeu là aussi je ne
veux pas faire de ma liste parce que je
pense que c'est pas vrai mais enfin je
pense que le plus grand bénéficiaire de
la crise aux mondiaux chine alors parce
qu'on a tout acheté la fnaut comme on
sait pas faire facture à tout acheter en
chine qu'un merci
alors monsieur gautier merci madame la
présidente
à titre personnel en tant que médecin
moi j'ai un a priori positif pour votre
démarche d'abord en ce qui concerne
votre carrière votre parcours des plus
preuve à faire
ensuite parce que vous avez bien
expliqué que beaucoup trop de personnes
au niveau de la planète et notamment
on avait des travaux chinois important
sur le sujet on vient d'en parler et
puis parce que les résultats à marseille
ce soit en terme de mortalité de
létalité sont bien meilleures
qu'ailleurs et ne serait ce que pour la
campagne de dépistage massif que vous
avez mené ça c'est vraiment le plus
remarquable en tant que médecin
biologiste au départ on m'a interdit de
faire des tests pcr des 1er mars
vous pouvez les faire sur les patients
qui n'était pas hospitalisé et en réa et
quand j'ai pu faire des tests
sérologiques le 1er avril comme le dit
surtout ça sert à rien on n'a pas fait
la preuve pour faire des études et c'est
donc dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
il faut une conduite exceptionnelle et
puis une réponse exceptionnelle et pas
forcément des études randomisées qui
sont très longues très cher alors je
voudrais avoir votre avis d'une part sur
les essais cliniques coûteux cher avec
une lourdeur administrative pas toujours
compatibles avec la réaction d'urgence
d'une crise sanitaire
évidemment laissé discovery on allait
voir ce qu'on allait voir nous avait-on
dit bossé dur de tirer sur une ambulance
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut qualifier
ça de retard n'aura peut-être des
résultats pour la fin de la crise
est ce que c'est un échec est ce que
c'est un fiasco tous à vous mettre dans
un cadre européen sous l'égide de
l'inserm on a parlé un petit peu tout à
l'air en disant que c'était coupé du
monde hospitalier en grande partie et
puis votre avis sur les conflits
d'intérêts ça n'avait déjà pas mal parlé
notamment avec avec gilead que ce soit
au niveau du conseil scientifique au
niveau du haut conseil de la santé
publique et liens avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique le président du haut
conseil de la santé publique
lui même a reconnu l'absurdité de la vie
prononcée et les pressions subies
merci
en coach vois je merci je préfère le
compliment aux insultes donc merci mais
je pense qu'il ya des phénomènes qui
sont structurels qui dépasse le fait que
encore une fois il ya des hommes la kiné
de mon point de vue était pas leur place
mais il ya des phénomènes structurels de
fonds dont j'ai parlé et qui je pense
continue à rester il faut il faudra bien
réaliser que il faudra faire de la
médecine et de la recherche médicale
avec les médecins dans dans les hôpitaux
en général et que ceux ci ne soient pas
préempté par des des gens dont ça n'est
plus dedans ça n'est plus métier je
crois que c'est ça pour vous concernant
les essais et là aussi je jeu j'ai honte
de vous ramener une fois de plus haut au
rapport que j'avais fait au ministre en
2003 en disant il faut faire attention
et ça je ne vous ai pas dit c'est encore
mais c'est quelque chose que je pense
très profondément vous savez on a vécu
un siècle et demi de progrès qui était
entièrement basée sur l'innovation et
l'innovation admettez que les molécules
dure vingt ans mais les molécules c'est
éternel
d'accord ça ne peut pas durer vingt ans
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe au bout de
vingt ans avec les molécules déjà à
l'époque je disais personne a prévu de
financer les études de recherche
thérapeutique basée sur des molécules
qui ne sont qu' son générique et qui ne
sont plus qu ils ne font plus l'objet de
presse profite donc dans cette
je voudrais que ce soit très clair si ça
n'allait pas je dis que moi je le
reprendrai dans ce virage de notre
époque qui est qu'on va pas se trouver
si vous voyez le nombre de médicaments
qui change son plan thérapeutique depuis
le 21e siècle il y en a extrêmement peut
pratiquement exclusivement sur le cancer
et pour ce qui nous concerne manière
fixeuse d'hépatite c c'est tout le reste
c'est entièrement marché donc qui est
pourtant l'industrie pharmaceutique n'a
jamais été aussi florissantes donc on
est un changement vrai modèle et comment
on appelle ce que nous on appelle le
repositionnement des molécules les
molécules qui ont 50 cent ans 70 ans
qu'on utilise à autre chose qui payent
pour faire ses études
puisque l'état a pris l'habitude que ce
soit ceux qui développent la nouvelle
technologie qui payent pour la mettre en
place
donc je soulevais ce problème encore une
fois en 2003
donc il ya une vraie question ces
molécules sont éternelles elles ont des
activités beaucoup plus ce serait
scientifiquement extrêmement complexe de
vous l'expliquer je pense qu'il ya un 4
sur 5 des gens qui font de la science
dure qui comprend mal parce que je dis
pas que pour dire les antibiotiques sont
une molécule qui ont trois milliards
d'années et qui sont multifonctionnel on
ne les connaît que ce pourquoi on les a
testées mais vous savez bien qu'il ya
des anticancéreux qui sont des
antibiotiques et les antiviraux qui sont
les antibiotiques
il ya des antibactériens qui sont des
antibiotiques d'accord et donc on croit
naïvement ses autres notre perception
arrogante de l'homme que ce pourquoi on
l'a testé c'est ce à quoi ils servent
elles servent à autre chose
de multiples choses et donc si on veut
les utiliser à autre chose que ce à quoi
on les a utilisés
personne ne paye alors dans un monde
comme le nôtre où il faut trouver un
modèle économique faire donner le
monopole du zonage à quelqu'un qui est
un laboratoire qui va recycler
repositionner la molécule où il faut que
les états se substitue pour ces
molécules qui sont dites génériques et
mais vous pouvez pas laisser ce champ
complètement à l'abandon et au fait que
les individus vont avoir les moyens ou
pas d'évaluer des molécules anciennes
dont on connaît on a un avantage
phénoménal je m'excuse dit ça par
rapport à m d'ici lire nous on savait
très bien ce que c'était à toxicité roxy
claudine et on sait bien que c'est
beaucoup moins toxique or m
dire qu'ils donnent des insuffisances
rénales on sait bien ça parce qu'un
molécules en qu'ancienne on connait
entièrement sa sécurité
quand ça a été prescrit deux milliards
de fois on connaît la sécurité des
molécules est une molécule qui nappe qui
a été testé chez 1000 ou 2000 personnes
vous connaissez pas les problèmes de
sécurité
vous ne connaissez que les problèmes
grossier ce qu'ils convoient dans 10 à
20 %
mais ce qui arrive une fois pour mille
ou une fois pour des mythes vous les
connaissez pas et donc il ya une espèce
d'inversion quand vous avez une molécule
un ancien vous connaissez beaucoup plus
d'effets secondaires oui mais ils sont
rarissimes et même la manière de
déterminer à la pharmaco vigilance et le
degré de causalité sur des choses qui
sont rarissimes on n'arrive jamais à
l'établir mais vous êtes obligés du coup
vous avez un papier plus la molécule est
ancien plus les effets secondaires sont
théoriquement important parce que juste
elle a été prescrit plus stamm l'effet
mécanique
alors coup oui bien sûr il ya encore
cinq parlementaires qui ont des
questions à poser donc c'est pas un
dialogue quoi très bien non je lui il y
avait d'autres questions pardon parce
qu'il ya des personnes qui sont
inscrites depuis un moment qui attendent
donc par respect pour nos collègues je
vais laisser tout le monde parlait donc
david habib merci madame la présidente
monsieur le professeur
bonjour je vous posais une première
question qu'ils savent et oui ou non et
vous verrez après je me permettrai de
faire un commentaire pour la poste vous
at on demandé une déclaration publique
d'intérêts lorsque vous êtes rentré au
conseil scientifique vos conseils
scientifiques
oui d'accord je le dis parce que à
l'aller coûte 2 je suis pas médecin et l
écoute des des différentes interventions
il me semble que la présidente on doit
une commission denquête c'est aussi ça
il me semble que sur cette question des
questions de cette question des conflits
d'intérêts il faut qu'on puisse
travailler davantage et puis tout être
que faudra peut-être faire une autre
commission d' enquête sur les conflits
d'intérêts dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique mais on s'éloigne un peu
de de ce qui nous amène aujourd'hui
deuxième point j'arrive pas très bien
comprendre monsieur le professeur
le 11 mai le président de la république
disait nous n'allons pas tester tous les
français cela n'aurait aucun sens
et cette phrase elle a été reprise par
tous les fonctionnaires de l'état
moi j'ai va se reconnaître la déléguée
de la rs dans mon département le plus
beau celui d'hibernia atlantic qui
disait alors que je lui parlais des
tests sérologiques avec une une autorité
définitive monsieur le député ça ne sert
à rien ce n'est pas validée en france et
ce discours là on l'a entendu pendant
toute cette période
et pourtant le même emmanuel macron qui
disait ça na li sert à rien de tester
vous a reconnu que a reconnu que vous
avez raison sur la question des tests
alors moi j'arrive pas à comprendre ça
il l'a dit le 28 mai qu'est-ce qui a
fait que entre le 11 mai et le 28 mai le
président de la république ait pu
changer d'avis sur votre analyse et sur
la question des tests si je vous dit ça
et je vais conclure madame la présidente
c'est que au delà du 30 mille morts il
ya un sentiment général d'un fiasco en
termes de communication terrible dans ce
dossier et qu'il nous faudra et le
rapporteur est là pour ça il nous faudra
nous appesantir aussi sur les allers et
retours des pouvoirs publics sur la
question des masques sur la question des
tests sur la question des respirateurs
parce que nous avons perdu du temps en
changeant d'avis si souvent merci si
c'est une question c'est que je vous
réponde jeu en tout cas j'ai un
commentaire souffrir je suis un
commentaire aussi nous vivons
l'écosystème si vous me permettez dans
lequel vous vivez vous et le même
écosystème que l'écosystème des médias
en grande partie au moins pour les gens
qui sont aux affaires et ça amène une
vitesse de réactivité qui à mon avis est
un problème et donc je vois moi je
encore une fois je regarde pas tes
vision jeu
par radio je lis rarement journaux donc
je suis pas perturbé maintenant je suis
perturbée quand on dit des horreurs je
m'en fou que je n'ai pas entendu campus
j'ai interdit aux tous les gens autour
de moi de m'en parler donc simples
peuvent lire tant qu'on veut sur le dit
ça m'indiffère ces légendes conseils
donnez vous dites que j'en dise du mal
de vous portez pas plainte j'ai même pas
qui c'est mais je ne les connais pas
donc je pense qu'il y à une
sollicitation trop importante justement
de communication et que cet excès de
communication nu à la communication
moi je peux vous dire mais vous avez vu
le nombre de gens qui viennent
photographier nombre de sollicitations
que je peux avoir noyé pas souvent
parler de la télévision je refuse comme
je le refuse de venir ici je suivrai
provincial moi je ne viens pas sur les
plateaux de télévision jean restreint le
visage je suis aussi avare que possible
parce que je pense que d'abord plus on
pas plus on dit bêtise et plus il ya de
chance pour 10 des bêtises
statistiquement ces statistiques
donc il faut pas trop parler parce que
la chance que l'on dise des bêtises
devient de plus en plus important en
plus on part et comme qui plus est on
oublie ce qu'on a dit quelques jours
avant si on parle tous les jours
il finit par y avoir quelqu'un comme
vous qui êtes vous et issa comme telle
journée 10 à tel jour et ce n'est pas
exactement
michel peremans oui professeur à autun
bonjour il faut tuer le messager vous
l'avais répété maintes fois
rassurez vous rassurez vous nous sommes
des parlementaires que nous soyons
d'accord ou pas avec vous nous sommes là
en tant que parlementaire donc je vais
poser mes petites questions et ça sera
rapide
considérez vous toujours que
l'association entre l'hydro l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et l'antibiotique
azithromycine constitue aujourd'hui le
meilleur traitement pour les patients
atteints de kobe 19 pouvez vous nous
indiquer la manière et les conditions
sous lesquelles ce traitement a été
administré aux patients qu'aux
de 10h et de méditerranée quelles ont
été les conséquences pour l'image pu au
décret du 26 mai abrogeant les
dispositions dérogatoires autorisant la
prescription de l'hydro hydrofuge et du
mal toujours avec l'hydro hydroxy
chloroquine à l'hôpital alors oui je
crois qu'il doit être disponible
aujourd'hui ou pire sinon demain on a
fait un énorme article ce qui je crois
le plus dense et le plus complet sur
cette maladie au monde sans à rouen
c'est à dire il ya trois mille sept
cents patients qu'on a fouillé des pieds
la tête
il a fallu 100 personnes pour ça que
quand il ya quatre personnes qui disent
que qui sont capables de 90 mille trucs
je ne peux pas le croire
il a fallu 100 personnes et heureusement
on a eu des étudiants volontaires qui
sont venus rentrer toutes ces données il
a fallu 100 médecins volontaires parce
qu'ils étaient confinés pour téléphoner
au patient quand il était positif et
leur donner des conseils pour les faire
revenir en hôpital de jour
donc si vous voulez ronde à des données
qui sont extraordinairement
extraordinaire danse donc chez les gens
qui ont pu recevoir pour évaluer un
traitement il faut qu'ils aient trois
jours traitement ses traditionnels pour
les pneumonies
c'est pas nous qui avons inventé ça n'a
toujours 10 pour l'efficacité d'un
traitement donne 72 heures ça a été
inventé à l'époque on a trouvé les
légionelles pour faire la différence
entre les infections à legionella
pneumophila donc on donne un traitement
au bout de 72 heures ça marche pas on
change donc cesser c'est quelque chose
qui est traditionnel depuis des années
70 ça donc nous on se donne trois jours
pour évaluer le traitement dans ces
conditions là chez les gens qui ont reçu
ce traitement nous avons une mortalité
de 0 5%
donc dans les conditions dans lesquelles
nous l'utilisons on voit pas nous
pourrons changer mais s'il ya des gens
qui trouvent mieux que ça tant mieux on
changera nous aussi ont du coup certains
n'ont pas voulu l'un ou n'ont pas voulu
l'autre où le médecin n'a pas voulu le
dos n'est pas ce qu'il ya sur chaque
médecin c'est pas une dictature à chaque
médecin est libre de sa prescription
individuellement on donne des
recommandations et les médecins sont
libres de leurs prescriptions
individuellement et puis d'autres n'ont
rien du tout donc on a pu comparer les
groupes et montrer que ceux qui avaient
reçu ce traitement avait
un taux de d'hospitalité durée
d'hospitalisation passage en gare de
mortalité qui était inférieure aux
autres ce que nous faisons très
précisément c'est pour pour éviter qu'il
y ait des problèmes c'est que nous
faisons systématiquement 1eroctobre
cardiogramme nous sommes mis d'accord
avec un des neuf ou dix professeur de
cardiologie de marseille mais celui qui
est spécialisée dans l'analyse du rythme
et avec son équipe ils nous ont analysé
tous les électrocardiogrammes d'accord
pour être sûr qu'elle ait pas de bêtises
on a arrêté le traitement je crois dans
six cas parce qu'il commençait à voir un
allongement de cul tu es d'accord donc
on a arrêté par sécurité et ce sont les
gens qui s'est connus de la littérature
j'ai des gens qui sont très âgées chez
les gens qui n'est pas de
polypathologies chez qui on voit ça ou
d'autres médicaments qui est qui et qui
sont connus pour ça et avant de les
traiter aussi on fait la calle me on
avait même planté dans le salir le
dosage du potassium
on sait qu'il faut pas avoir un
potassium bas alors on peut leur donner
du potassium et lyon voire 48 heures
après quand le poids de cette somme est
remonté parce que le potassium bas
favorisent ce type de risque d'accord et
donc du coup on s'est mis plutôt que de
l'envoyer leur service de biochimie à
faire nous mêmes les dosages de
potassium pour les avoir dans les dix
minutes quand il était en hôpital de
jour pour pouvoir voir si on les
traitait aussi on les traitait pas c'est
c'est comme ça ce sont les traitements
qu'on l'a fait plus tout ça est entourée
des soins ordinaires c'est à dire qu'ils
étaient iso puis antico réguler mais
attendue lente il était hospitalisé dans
la 730 qui ont été hospitalisés et leur
s ont été traités en hôpital de jour
c'est à dire un premier jour de
diagnostic un premier jour hospitalisées
pour avoir éventuellement un skate tous
ceux qui étaient hospitalisés ou
pratiquement tous et beaucoup des
hôpitaux de jour avait un scan l'aude
aux jets insiste beaucoup encore une
fois sur le fait que le le une des
choses qui est significativement
inférieure dans ce pays par rapport à la
moyenne des pays de l'osce et d'élever
le niveau d'équipement radiologique
donc c'est une catastrophe de télé
thorax aurait dû être remplacée par les
scans au dos depuis très longtemps et
donc ça a commencé le rattrapage a
commencé il faut continuer s'il ya
vraiment qu la de d'équipement et donc
on a fait le maximum on en a fait 2400
les radiologues ont été aussi il a
incroyablement efficace travailler le
jour la nuit et week-end pour pouvoir
faire le maximum de ce qu'on pouvait
faire
et donc je vous dis on a découvert dans
ses comptes
des lésions pulmonaires chez les gens
qui étaient prétendu asymptomatique et
ont regardé bien entendu effectivement
leur leur saturation en oxygène donc en
fonction des paramètres si on
considérait qu'il y avait un certain
danger on les hospitaliser sinon on les
suivait à la maison est-ce que ça ça
vous satisfait comme intense ça le satis
il reste un peu de temps mais je le
prendrais pas tout on n'avait pas
répondu concernant les hacher
méditerranée c'est à dire si nous bien
si vous avez globalement vous savez à
mon âge je sais pas mystère j'ai 68 ans
vous savez ma carrière est derrière moi
c'est cissé a mis très longtemps et le
le nombre d'obstacles qu'il ya pour
faire quelque chose qui était
entièrement nouveau vous savez on
n'avait pas fait un institut de
recherche en maladies infectieuses
depuis institut pasteur quand même donc
pour faire quelque chose je peux vous
dire que le nombre d'oppositions a été
absolument gigantesque à toutes les
étapes
tout a été difficile donc je suis
content si à la fin on arrive à faire la
preuve de concept qu'il faut faire ça
c'est pas juste une lubie de dire à
moult jeux c'est sur ce très satisfait
je pense que j'aurai fait mon devoir
à côté du fait qu' il s'est passé une
chose tout à fait extraordinaire c'est
que un le personnel entier s'est sentie
d'une mission
incroyable le les gens b comme ailleurs
applaudissez tous les soirs le personnel
de soins à victor du soir en tapant sur
des tambours des gens étaient fiers de
travailler là le chu de marseille avait
été beaucoup critiqué ces dernières
années mais le chu entier à participer à
ça les gens sont sentir valorisés on n'a
eu pratiquement pas l'absentéisme et on
a eu vraiment vraiment les gens ont une
une volonté de faire quelque chose qui
était spectaculaire et pour l'y a chu ça
a été une très grande chose pour nous je
vous assure on recevait des cadeaux
touche patients déclarés au fisc
on recevait des repas gratuits pour tous
personnels tous les jours on se fait du
vin recevez ensuite détection prise
illégale d'intérêts 1
et donc si vous voulez oui je crois que
ça a été très bon pour le personnel
c'est le personnel hospitalier très
fragile en ce moment le personnel
hospitalier a été rassuré sur sa mission
a considéré qu'il faisait sa mission il
était heureux de la faire
ils n'ont pas compté leurs heures dans
une situation de moi j'étais un peu
comme je vous le dis je suis un peu
réservés je trouve que notre société est
fragile mais là j'ai été enthousiasmée
moi même je ne pouvais pensez pas qu'il
pouvait y avoir un tel enthousiasme une
chose aussi dynamisante si vous voulez
que de deux d'avoir une crise en ayant
le sentiment qu'on s'en occupe
merci josaine corps de l'eau merci
madame la présidente simplement deux
petites questions professeur il y a des
dizaines de milliers de patients qui
prennent quotidiennement d'hydroxyde
rockin pour des maladies articulaires
d'origine inflammatoires j'en ai moi
même délivré plan plus de 30 ans en tant
que pharmacien est ce que nous savons
aujourd'hui si ces patients étaient
moins atteints par le coronavirus ou non
est ce que ce travail a été réalisé
et puis ma deuxième question je vais
revenir sur l'interdiction de
prescription hydroxyque eurokin nous
avons auditionné il ya quelques jours le
professeur salomon je les ai interrogés
à cet effet il m'a expliqué que la
médiatisation de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
étant importante et risquait d'y avoir
une automédication qui était très
augmentée et donc des risques inhérents
en fait lorsqu'on décortique les
chiffres on s'aperçoit que les risques
effectivement vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit ne sont pas aussi important que cela
mais surtout le m'interroge si
effectivement nous voulions pas lié à
cette automédication qui aurait pu être
développé pourquoi ce moment ne pas
listé la molécule pourquoi interdire la
prescription aux médecins et je voulais
avoir votre avis qu'est ce qui peut
justifier aujourd'hui l'interdiction de
prescription de cette molécule par des
médecins donc comme vous le dites c'est
une molécule banal moi personnellement
je vous ai donné mon avis je ne je ne
comprends pas que l'on puisse interdire
une molécule qui a été encore une fois
l'année dernière a été prescrite gens
qu'il ya eu 36 millions de comprimés qui
ont été distribués en france est
brutalement sans ambiance et du jour au
lendemain on décide que l'on peut même
plus délivrés sur ordonnance
je ne comprends pas je ne l'approuvent
pas jeudi
je ne cherche pas la vie et je vois là
donc je vous le dis à vous je me suis
gardé de vous avez alors ça bien sûr et
je m'en suis ouvert là j'ai le devoir de
vous répondre donc je vous réponds mais
je n'ai jamais recommandé ce traitement
parce que je n'ai pas le droit de
recommander un traitement qui est hors
jeu peu pâlot commandes et je peux dire
ce que je fais donc mais je peux pas
recommandé et de j'ai jamais recommandé
si vous écoutez bien ce que je dis je
dis ce que je fais je vous recommande
pas c'est peut-être une nuance mais
c'est une nuance qu'elles sont
importants ce qui est bien entendu je
pense que j'ai le devoir d'informer les
gens et donc oui je forme les gens ce
que j'informe après je m'excuse mais ça
ce jeune femme les gens quand on a un
papier qui est en train d'être publiés
qui devient public donc il n'y a pas de
je n'ai pas de raison de ne pas informer
de jeu travaux que nous avons faits qui
sont publiques
je n'ai pas fait j'ai pas annoncé que
effectivement lentilles l6 était en
train de bouleverser la thérapeutique à
paris je viens de lire une méta-analyse
parce que quand on est dans le domaine
était bien sûr on sait les choses un peu
avant les autres moi je review 3,4
papier sur le co vide coup qu'on
m'envoie toutes les revues du monde par
jour donc souffler tout ce qui se passe
je sais le relativement précocément et
j'ai revu encore très récemment une
méta-analyse dont on parlait sur le
petit corps dans l'eau clonale que
monsieur hirsch a annoncé comme étant un
miracle au petit soin qu'elle n'a aucune
différence actuellement tous les essais
qui ont été faits normandin donc faut
faire attention quand on annonce des
choses qu'on les annonce au moment où le
papier est accepté ou déposer quelque
part c'est qu'on peut déposer les
papiers maintenant nous on les comprend
le déposer sur notre site de manière à
ce qu'ils soient les gens puissent
vérifier que ce que vous dites ne soit
pas un futur des accords avec les
annonces que qu'avait fait prématurément
recouvrit où ça aussi avant que le
papier sont disponibles dont il faut que
le papier soit disponible au moment que
les gens puissent voir ou puisse voir
l'abstract de ce que vous avez fait au
moment où vous l'annoncer
merci principes scientifiques
valérie rapaud puis merci madame la
présidente monsieur professeur j'aurais
cinq questions rapides
vous avez nommé rapid vous avez parlé de
l'immunité croisée du coc vite de
lakovic 19 avec d'autres coronavirus qui
expliquerait la protection des enfants
vis-à-vis de la copie de 19
est ce que on pourra évaluer cette
immunité croisés pour le reste de la
population
deuxième question vous nous avez fait
part de votre scepticisme sur un
potentiel vaccins dont pour vous quelle
est l'option de recherche thérapeutique
à privilégier
troisième question sur les chiffres est
ce que moi je suis d'accord avec vous je
trouve qu'il ya peu de chiffres
notamment des segmentations en tout cas
à partir des données brutes ce que vous
pensez qu'on les aura un jour
quatrième point vous m'avez déprimé sur
la recherche scientifique je dois bien
le dire ce que j'aime beaucoup les
sciences et vous aviez écrit dans une
tribune en 2018 que vous regrettiez que
la science soit instrumentalisée au
service de l'idéologie et du commerce
alors comment on peut casser ça je n'ai
pas de solution miracle mais en tout cas
le la description vous en avez fait tout
à l'heure je les trouvais un peu
angoissante
on va dire ça comme ça et dernière
question sur la deuxième vague la
deuxième qui la question vous avez déjà
été posée précédemment mais votre
sentiment c'est quoi vous savez petit à
petit vous connaissez des objets je n'ai
pas beaucoup de sentiments sur le sur
l'avenir je sais pas banale chute donc
je suis je crois que si j'ai un talent
dans la science et l'observation j'ai un
bon observateur je vois les choses là où
les gens ne voient pas mais je suis pas
un prophète un même si je suis barbu je
ne suis pas pour faire du tout donc je
prophétise pas ce qui va se passer
d'urgence rien eux mêmes sur quelque
chose qui est aussi bête que la grippe
vous voulez on n'arrive pas à savoir si
on va voir et puis immigrés h1n1 ou de
hp n 3 et d'après des fois il y en a pas
du tout des fois y'a d'la baie et 20
c'est d'une complexité de l'évolution
des maladies infectieuses qui est très
grande
deuxièmement moi aussi je partage je
pense qu'il ya une véritable réflexion à
mener sur la recherche médicale sur son
orientation en particulier sur la
créativité
moi je trouve je suis imagine que ça se
voit je suis extrêmement heureuse de
faire mes études ne vous inquiétez pas
je sais que pas de faire le vôtre
il ya aucune chance sauf si on me fout
de leurs mais honnêtement encore je
trouve à quelque chose d'autre à faire
que j'adore écrire c'est ce qui m'a été
reproché on demandait comment j'aurais
aimé écrire autant parce que j'aime ça
j'ai facilité pour ça et donc je je je
suis extrêmement heureux parce que notre
période et merveilleuse mais je trouve
que nos pays mais mais l'ensemble de
leurs passes à côté alors que l'extrême
orient on trouve on est dans un pays
dans le monde et dans un monde dans
lequel l'enjeu est un enjeu des
découvertes technologiques ce que ce
qu'on nous on appelle les eaux mixte qui
ont commencé avec le génome ou déjà la
france a pris un retard colossal ont été
les seuls vols à faire du génome
l'institut pasteur disait que le génome
c'est les bêtises que ça servait à rien
et donc nous on s'est mis à faire les
fous et les génomes dont la part est et
on fait du des manants des séquences
permanente tout tous les jours tous les
jours on décide de faire le génome d'une
bactérie parce qu'il ya un effet
atypique
on essaie de comprendre pourquoi et puis
il ya eu les autres c'est maintenant un
léger les génomes 2 et bien sûr c'est
comme ça qu'on découvre les virus de il
ya les protéines 3 la morphologie quatre
cultures dans tous les azimuts la voyez
pour répondre à la question que s'est
posée sur le vaccin rougeole on a isolé
sens où je vis de rougeole qu'on ait
tout en train de séquencer pour regarder
s'il ya de la variabilité pour expliquer
sa wii donc il ya des choses qui sont
donc je trouve que cette époque est un
miracle pour quelqu'un qui fait de la
biologie de la mire de la microbiologie
c'est merveilleux mais c'est pas là
dedans qu'on va et donc les derniers
arrivants vous savez c'est souvent comme
ça les derniers arrivants se sont mis
juste à faire ce qui arrivait sur sur
lequel il avait aucun retard et donc ils
ont commencé un suréquipement massif
c'est ce qu'on a vu en chine ce qu'on
voit en corée
une technologie de pointe extraordinaire
qui va nous fournir et qu'il ya un
développement industriel hallucinant
donc c'est il ya une révolution
quotidiennes actuellement de ça qui est
enthousiasmante qui est merveilleuse
mais si je m'exprime de temps en temps
des temps amer c'est parce que c'est pas
moi je vous assure que nous on s'amuse
beaucoup beaucoup c'est très
excessivement intéressant l'on trouve
qu'on publie beaucoup mais j'ai il ya
encore 150 nouvelles espèces
bactériennes que l'on a décrit qu on a
rigolé chez l'homme qu'on n'a pas le
temps de décrire tellement on a deux
choses qui sortent donc c'est
merveilleux comme temps je regrette que
cesse cette mutation de la science et de
la recherche médicale ne soit pas
adoptée plus généralement c'est ça que
je regrette
et si vous voulez honnêtement pour vous
dire les essais thérapeutiques en
maladies infectieuses honnêtement ça
représente un intérêt qui est
extrêmement modestes on a besoin de très
très très très peu de choses équipe usée
il faut changer les modèles de pensée
c'est à dire que les modèles d croit en
tout cas c'est ce que nous on avait fait
les modèles therapeutics et c'est pas le
faire des études randomisées soûlé
savoir si un médicament qui marche
baptisée ou par le sida vous faites une
charge virale et puis vous ne savez
regarder si virus disparaisse s'ils
disparaissent ces gens sont plus malades
au bout de quelques temps ça aurait pu
entraîner des baisses considérables du
coût du traitement de l'hépatite c
s'ils ont décidé vous vouliez qu'après
trois tests ou la charge virale est
devenue négative en arrêter le
traitement
et puis on les surveille et puis si ça
recommence on les retraites voyez pas
jusque là on a imposé une durée de
traitement qui est événement imposé qui
était pas basée alors comme une
variabilité considérable d'un patient à
l'autre
tout ça c'est pas de la médecine trois
cdc 0,7 séoul et est donc encore une
fois je voudrais bien je serais heureux
que jean se saisissent de cette
opportunité extraordinaire moi je dis
microbiologie c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut faire de moins en moins de
théorie c'est on est exactement si vous
voulez au xvième siècle en géographie
on est en train de découvrir le mans on
est en train de découvrir le microbiote
en train de découvrir que tout ça change
complètement
vous savez ce que c'est le médicament
que révolutionnaire qu'on ait eue dans
le 21e siècle pour les maladies
infectieuses
traitement de pâtissier qui avait
commencé vous savez ce que c'est la
greffe et car si honteux c'est à dire
qu'on sauve des gens n'ont sauvé au
moins 150 en leur faisant des greffes
fécales donc vous voyez que l'innovation
ou s'est trouvée l'innovation comment on
va remplacer cette innovation c'est
quand même ces espèces de biens comme la
gale fécales en séries tout le monde
sait qu'il doit le commercialiser or des
causes des tripeux pas rapporté d'argent
pas le contrôler comment on va faire
avec ça aurait donc c'est un sujet terim
ça et pourtant ça c'est la maladie
émergente a plus qu'on a eu la plus
violente depuis 20 ans en france
cette huile de 1500 personnes par an en
france déclaré je sais pas si c'est
représente la moitié de celles qui sont
réelles donc il ya des choses
merveilleuses affaire extraordinaire ça
le microbiote extraordinaire en ces
temps on découvre un monde sait pas ce
que ça va donner
est ce que c'est ça qui fait payer les
changements d'écosystèmes esquissons
médiée par les microbes
voyez ce que l'effet du froid est plutôt
sur les microbes des muqueuses nasales
qui les rendrait plus qui est qui nous
rendrait plus vulnérable voyez donc on
est dans un monde découverte qui est
julien qui est extraordinaire donc je
sais ça que je regrette c'est que la
course n'est pas nous qui la faisons en
tête
je ne croyais pas nous irons le fond
quand on est compétitif avec les chinois
mais au prix d'un équipement massif
d'une stratégie d' usage des outils
actuels à ce qui est en train de sortir
maintenant maintenant tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps et c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure il est sorti un
appareil apc qui fait les pcr en 20
minutes vient de corée on nous
l'envoyons nous envoie tout pour tester
qui vient de corée qui est grand comme
ça et vous faites le test mettez le
prélèvement de sang de ce que voulait
vingt minutes après et alors
qu'actuellement il nous faut deux heures
quarante sera un truc de cabinet donc
ils vont vous aurez besoin de réfléchir
sur les docteurs test est ce qu'on
pourra faire ça au cabinet oui ça va
changer complètement la prise en charge
de t'envoyer donc comment tout ça va
s'harmoniser avec la loi actuelle la
place des biologistes y avoir bien si on
accepte de regarder ce qui est en train
de se passer dans le monde et la vitesse
à laquelle ça se développe
vous aurez des génomes humains demain on
fera le génome entier c'est pas pour 100
dollars je sais pas vous avez vu les
trucs de trois petits sous et demi ça
coût de 100 $ essor aux états unis et
puis on vous prédit ce que vous allez
voir que mal face et ça notre monde
c'est un monde fou de vitesse de
technique c'est intéressant et si les
médicaments on utilise des vieux débats
très grave
merci on a encore deux parlementaires
qui veulent poser des questions vous
m'avez pas répondu monsieur le
professeur sur l'immunité croisés alors
il ya on trouve honteux travail a su
bien sûr quand on parle de quelque chose
bien sûr ça va pas on essaie de ne pas
se laisser dépasser
il ya une immunité croisés en
particulier avec le virus nous enfin
pour pour l'instant on n'a pas de
modèles expérimentaux mais on a pris des
gens qui avaient fait des infections par
des virus
corona on a beaucoup à plus de 2000 cas
et que chez qui on avait par hasard un
sérum pour regarder s'ils avaient des
anticorps contre avec ce que l'on voit
ce qui est significatif c'est celui qui
est plus près qui s'appelle hk hu a plus
souvent des anticorps contre le coc vite
que tous les autres ça on a ça pour
l'instant c'est ce qu'on a eu mais à
notre surprise ou peu pour des raisons
que je comprends mal en tout cas qui ait
pas l'hypothèse que j'avais au départ on
n'a pas pu suivre si on fait de la
sérologie
en général on n'a pas plus d'anticorps
celle et les enfants qu'on en a chez les
sujets avec une technique ultra sensible
à nouveau ensemble rock et donc il y a
des réactions croisées maintenant est-ce
que les l'immunité des enfants et est un
fera n'est pas détecté c'est bien
possible puisque le premier papier qui a
été publiée au montré de l'immunité est
trouvé entre 40 et 70 % ce qui est
beaucoup plus que nous et regarder
l'humanité cellulaire des lymphocytes
mémoire donc ce qui a plus de mémoire
notre corps ces lymphocytes mémoire et e
on peut trouver mémoire chez eux contre
pas sûr en regardant simplement les
anticorps même avec des tests très
subtil et donc c'est possible mais il
faudra arriver à ça or
dans les dents les virus en particulier
hqe a eu l'idée d'une difficulté
effroyable à cultiver et donc c'est pas
facile de produire des choses avec ça
donc on travaille avec une équipe
d'immunologie ce qu'ils sont des stars
parisiennes qui sont les meilleurs au
monde de mon point de vue actions de
laurent d'hydrogène et guides aux
primaires pour essayer de regarder ce
qui se passe dans les infos site mémoire
et de voir si les anticorps convois sont
des anticorps croit fin à l'immunité
qu'on voit passer pas les anticorps et
croisées entre les autres coronas la
bolivie servat merci madame la
présidente monsieur le professeur out
la france est la france parce que les
archipélagique parce que le soleil ne se
couche jamais sur les trois océans grâce
à ses territoires ultramarins sur les
trois océans
il se trouve que le virus nous a touchés
en outre-mer de façon variée très peu
pour beaucoup le territoire d'ailleurs
dix des onze territoires ultramarins
sont finalement tropicaux avec des
températures élevées toute l'année avec
un taux d'humidité important sauf sa
pierre et miquelon
donc j'aimerais savoir deux choses la
première c'est que est-ce que vous
identifier une raison ou un lien entre
la propagation et l'intensité du virus
et les températures et les taux
d'humidité et deuxième question nous
avons deux territoires aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont plus sévèrement touchés que
d'autres c'est mayotte et la guyane
est-ce que vous avez des explications à
ce taux de contamination plus élevé
qu'ailleurs
non la glâne c'est tout c'est non c'est
non mais en l'épidémie c'est jusqu'à yen
n'en où c'est toute la bmc tout en
guyane et y compris
du côté de la frontière brésilienne avec
le brésil
non honnêtement le jeu
je ne sais pas pau pour une maladie qui
a été beaucoup beaucoup plus étudiée
comme le la grippe on arrive mal à
comprendre quels sont les facteurs dans
la zone parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup moins de travaux dans la zone
intertropicale humide
c'est beaucoup moins de travaux que ce
qu'il ya eu dans le dans la zone
tempérée et donc déjà dans les zones
tempérées on comprend pas réellement la
saisonnalité
je sais pas le rôle que joue le dans la
grippe ce que je peux dire c'est que
c'est vrai que c'est la saison des plus
calmes plus c'est donc c'est pendant le
léthé tropicale qu' il ya le plus de cas
de grippe mais il y en a toute l'année à
la différence de ce qui passe dans les
pays tempérés
donc ce qui va se passer c'est une vraie
question c'est très important nous on
hâte de ses travaux avec beaucoup de
deux pays du sud
c'est une question qui va se poser c'est
comment ça va se placer là dans les mois
qui viennent est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
continuum
est-ce que ça va continuer parce que
bien entendu si c'est le cas ça veut
dire que ça peut être une source de
réaffectation dans un an et redéclencher
un épisode épidémique donc c'est une
vraie question très importante de
surveiller ce qui se passe ailleurs
bien sûr on l'a vu les virus b voyage
beaucoup c'est une vraie question je ne
sais pas y répondre parce que encore une
fois je ne sais pas 1 les conditions qui
détermine que mal dit épidémique à un
instant donné et dans un endroit donné
ce sont pas connues en général
voyez bien que même en france on
n'arrive pas à savoir pourquoi y en a
pas dans l'ouest et on a eu tellement
dans l'est même si on retrouve un
événement déclenchant donc je réellement
je suis ignorant mais je crois que tout
le monde l'est donc je ne sais pas il
faut observer parce que si on observe on
peut toujours imaginer que ce qui est
faux mais ce qui est moins faut que
d'inventer complètement
on peut imaginer que le
le futur semble en partie au passé donc
si on arrive à observer ce qui se passe
maintenant on n'y comprendra on y verra
plus clair mais pour l'instant à ce
stade là il faut parier en guyane il
faut tester tout ce qu'on peut il faut
essayer de collecter les choses voir
quelle est la cinétique de la courbe en
faisant des tests et les tests lte est
une aiguille à savon c'est un beau pays
mais je viens de la guadeloupe tableau
payer c'est un très beau pays
philippe berta merci madame la
présidente professeur deux petits points
là la lr la cueillette et pcr nous que
vous mentionnez donc sur le génome viral
c'est quoi aujourd'hui encore le taux de
faux négatifs ou de faux positifs
question qui peut se poser sur la
cuirasse idée des tests que vous
pratiquez deuxième point pour les temps
de cycle holding voulais mentionner
aussi c'est une vieille histoire
on voit les premières publications
effectivement au début des années 2000
avec des effets de sur l'entrée du virus
dans les cellules liées à des problèmes
de péage sur les endosomes en fermant
par entrer dans ces détails là mais
c'est comparer à d'autres molécules et
finalement même le pauvre l'ammonium a
grosso modo le même effet que la
chloroquine sur ses cultures de cellules
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
pourquoi on va pas plus loin ce moment
là en terme de recherche
puisqu'on était dans l'épisode sera ce
j'imagine dernier point vous avez
effectivement obtenu grâce au grand
emprunt l'un des plus beaux si la chute
de ce pays
l'une des rolls roce de l'infectiologie
mondiale la question que je me pose
quand même et je sais je suis pas la
seule à me poser mais pourquoi pourquoi
n'avez vous pas fait des essais
cliniques digne de ce nom dès le départ
qui aurait pu définitivement répondre
oui ou non les drogues cycle henry qui
n'a en effet pourquoi vous êtes vous
cantonner à des publications que vous
êtes je connais tous vos travaux sur les
risques et si je connais vos travaux sur
les maxi virus etc
donc je connais votre science bien
établie vous savez très bien qu'en
publiant ces pseudos et c'était un petit
que si le pseudo essais cliniques
en fait il n'était absolument pas
recevables par qui que ce soit parce que
quand on se retrouve sur une publication
à la fin avec six patients on sait très
bien que c'est pas un essai clinique
alors pourquoi
n'avait pas fait c'étaient ces cliniques
celle où titi tous dans dans notre
communauté
dès le départ c'est un peu facile de
remettre en cause le système des essais
thérapeutiques mais enfin c'est ce qui
se pratique et qui va se continuer à
pratiquer traverse tout simplement dans
l'affection logique y compris non je ne
suis pas d'accord avec ça d'une part ce
que nous avons fait c'est ce que ce que
ce que ce qui se fait le plus simplement
c'est à dire quand on fait un essai
thérapeutique si vous voulez quand les
choses deviennent significatives on n'a
cessé de l'éthique basale et l'éthique a
rien à voir avec la méthodologie ces
deux choses distinctes les types basale
c'est que quand on a la preuve que
quelque chose marche et on doit le faire
à mi-chemin canton la preuve que quelque
chose marche on arrête le sait et donc
je suis désolé que vous n'ayez pas mais
bon et c'est moi je les aime beaucoup et
je trouve qu'il a toutes les bases d'un
essai de la seule manière de faire des
essais et de faire des essais
comparatifs et d'avoir une différence
significative et contrairement à ce que
vous dites c'est ça alors là je m'excuse
mais alors c'est une erreur radical - ya
de gens quand c'est significatif et plus
c'est significatif
quand vous avez dix mille personnes vous
êtes obligés d'avoir dix mille personnes
dans un essai pour montech une
significativité c'est qu'il n'y a aucune
différence parce que je vais vous dire
il ya quinze pour cent des gens qui ne
prennent même pas les médicaments qu'on
l'a prescrit donc quand vous cherchez
des différences de 20%
vous n'êtes plus dans la médecine vous
êtes dans du fantasme méthodologique
donc tout essai qui comporte plus de
mille personnes est un essai qui
cherchent à démonter les choses qui
n'existent pas et je suis désolé c'est
une base de la statistique et je vous
assure que je suis un très bon m donc
c'est du fantasme qu'on voudrait qu'on
répète à tour de bras qui est véhiculée
par des gens qui sont des méthodologies
ce qu'ils ne comprennent rien à la
science la méthodologie n'est pas de la
science c'est un outil de la science ça
n'a rien à voir donc il faut pas me dire
que mes essais ne sont pas parce que
vous avez dit avant et c'est vrai je
suis un grand scientifique je sais ce
qui est un essai et je peux vous dire il
ya une dizaine d traitement que j'ai
inventés qui sont dans tous les livres
de référence médicaux et celui là il
sera aussi je vous le dis nous verrons
mais je peux vous dire et il faut
arrêter il faut les regarder les livres
médicaux il faut regarder un maladies
infectieuses combien il ya des sait
combien il y adeux thérapeutique qui
sont utilisés actuellement qui ont été
basées sur des essais randomisés et vous
verrez il y en a pas beaucoup et le peu
qui ya été en particulier pour le sida
totalement inutile parce qu'il suffisait
de faire des charges virales
c'est pas vrai c'est de l'intox c'est
pas vrai ça disparaîtra comme c'est
apparu il ya une vingtaine d'années
c'est de l'intox
je vous suggère d'ailleurs plutôt que
vous avez qu à lire parce que c'est
intelligent sur la version de wikipedia
en anglais vous avez qu à lire vous
verrez qu'il ya la moitié qui dit voilà
il faut faire des essais randomisés
l'autre moitié qui dit voilà pourquoi il
faut pas en faire et vous verrez que je
suis pas isolé lancement et que
globalement tous les gens font critiquer
ça je le redis d'ailleurs et il faut le
lire et il faut écouter ce que je dis
tous les gens qui ont critiqué sa non
publié que des essais comparatifs non
randomisé il n'y a pas un essai français
randomisés comparatif il n'y a pas même
un essai français qui est le degré de
2,2 d'isolement des stratégies
thérapeutiques comme d'autres 0 c'est
que des gens qui dans les hôpitaux ont
traité un peu comme ils voulaient à la
fin on dit regardez comment on compare
donc il faut pas mettre les choses à
l'envers
j'étais avant un grand scientifique et
je suis resté un grand scientifique
après avoir publié bien s'il n'y a plus
d'autres questions je vais vous
remercier infiniment confesseur out pour
la clarté de vos réponses et puis la
longueur de cette audition mais un grand
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui je m'associe madame la présidente à
vos remerciements je crois que cette
audition a été très dense très riche
avec avec beaucoup d'éléments
nous avons mesuré je crois à la fois vos
convictions mais on n'est pas dans un
sujet de conviction aux compétences
surtout votre expérience
je relève aussi avec gravité et c'est
naturellement pour notre commission
un sujet qui va déboucher sur des suites
sur des auditions au moins dans un
premier temps que vous avez porté des
graves et des accusations extrêmement
graves sur des instances qui sont
aujourd'hui installés et qui ont ouvert
la question des conflits d'intérêts nous
serons amené naturellement je le serai a
exploré cette voie que que vous nous
avez indiqué qu' que nous connaissions
naturellement mais vous l'avez fait
devant devant cette commission et
naturellement elle doit nous conduire à
en tirer toutes toutes les conséquences
en tout cas merci pour pour les éléments
que vous nous avez apporté pour
l'éclairage qui a été le vôtre est aussi
je veux le dire également pour pour
l'action sanitaire que vous avez
conduite pour notre pays je vous
remercie